12 of the strongest chess players in
america
are hungry and ready to fight to the
bitter end in the 2020 u.s chess
championship
over the course of 11 rounds these
competitors will battle for prize money
totaling 150 000
in 2019 hikaru nakamura took home a
remarkable fifth title
yeah i mean i think this one was really
difficult because
i had so many games that i thought were
must win and i found a way to win every
single one of them
but with past champions wesley so and
sam shanklin leading a powerful cadre
of chess warriors it's anyone's guess
who will win this year's championship
so
hello everyone and welcome back to
championship october
as we bring you our final event the
ultimate crown up for grabs
in the 2020 us chess championship
we're going to take you through over the
next four days
i'm jennifer shahadi and i am here with
yasser sarwan and maurice ashley as we
call this thrilling event
yes hello hello jen hello maurice hello
everyone
welcome and thank you for joining us and
sharing your day
this october has been four
championships but all building to this
juan tournament the u.s chess
championship where we'll be witnessing
12 of our finest players
playing for the overall title there's
been thrills and spills galore
already and we're going to see plenty
more maurice as we get
ready for this year's u.s chess
championship
we can only hope we have the same number
of thrills and spills in this one that
we've had so far
they have been some thrilling affairs
starting with the girls junior going
through the juniors
going to the seniors and the women with
arena crush winning her eighth title
and that jubilant double fist pump
when she ended it we can only hope these
these players the top players in the
country have that same kind of fire and
desire
and will to win this event and let's
take a look at
our roster players jet well we've got
wesley so at the top of the table but
it's defending
champion and hikaru nakamura also
up there as he is no doubt a rapid and
blitz and bullet legend
linear dominguez jeffrey zhang other
favorites
sam shanklin also a former champion and
lots of interesting names as well
as we see alejandra ramirez often on the
commentary or the coaching side
is playing in this event at the wild
card as well as our u.s open champion el
shawn maradi abadi
and our junior champ awander leon it's
going to be a great cast of characters
and here's a photo of our 2020
graduating class if you will quite a
quite an impressive lineup
as there you see them all yeah this is a
this is a great
great event yes it's always um my
favorite this in the u.s women's
championship
and holding them separately allows us to
completely focus on each event um
and this one i can't wait to see how it
goes down if you guys haven't been with
us for the previous
championships um i'll let you know how
it's gonna work
well it is a 12 play around robin and
that means we'll have three games a day
at this time control
game 25 with a five second increment
love this time control from a commentary
perspective
lots of time to go over some nice fees
in the opening and early middle game and
then
it inevitably gets kind of crazy yeah
with the blitz but always action this
action always throughout
especially with six games ongoing and
there's 150 thousand dollars up for
grabs
and we've got a a packed schedule four
days of action
three rounds a day and finally on the
championship thursday we'll have our
final two rounds and a playoff if we
need it
very nice and maurice you're gonna go
over some of
our uh last five years worth of winners
and
how they got there well indeed
it has been a tremendous event we've
been calling all these events all these
years
been such a thrill let's take a look at
championships
passed but only recently passed as we go
and start with 2015
and that looks like a familiar name at
the top hikaru nakamura
winning his fourth championship that
year
and the following players looks like an
olympic team
i think all of them have played it in
the olympics maybe not young sam sevion
look at him tied
for fifth what was he like 14 or 15 at
the time
tremendous result for him and in 2016 it
was the rise of
fabulous fabiano caruana his soul win we
thought he would win many more
after this but no this championship is
tough folks
number two there wesley so you see ikaru
nakamura coming in third
and this looks like a proper olympic
team so look at these five players
i certainly have represented the country
various times before
and in 2017 it was basically more of the
same except for flip at the top
wesley so winning his lone championship
as well and you see onus chuck the iron
man
always near the top and fabi and there's
ikaru
coming in fourth and our varusian
ocobian
coming in fifth var certainly always
competitive in these events in 2018 it
was a surprise result
sam shanklin that was storybook look at
the people he had to win a head off
bobby wesley and hikaru yet again
but hikaru now only tied for fourth a
bit of a disappointing result for him
still solid but he could do better
did he do better yeah he did i
definitely was predicting this one
uh 2019 hikaru nakamura
rises to the top he won his fifth
title that year everything fell his way
and we see again the cream is always
pretty close to the top people
he simply does well all the time but
everyone else
they're competitive hikaru has never won
two in a row he's won five but he's
never won
back to back as you see there over the
years usually three or four years
separating his championships his world
rapid rating fourth in the world
um i think a lot of people say he's
probably number one
or two at the moment he's been tearing
up the summer circuit this online chest
he's just been extraordinary in going
all the way to the y with magnus on the
magnus tour
simply incredible to play against he's
probably the runaway favorite guys
i mean he's certainly my pick to win
this event how can you say no
he's been an incredible force of nature
in these events
we'll see what he does to try to maybe
finally win back to back
blitz and rapid chess and nikara
nakamura's name you bet
that that's that's his belly wig and
let's take a look at the pairings for
round one jen kick it off get us started
well we got a big one and
lanier dominguez plays he carl blitz
nakamura
that sounds like a cool name doesn't it
i like that
lanier no slouch in blitz either former
world champ in fact so that one is
definitely the one to watch in terms of
favorites facing off
um i but all the parents are gonna give
us a lot of insight into who's on form
what opening surprises we might have in
store uh we didn't miss a wander leon
due to a scheduling conflict at the
us junior so i'm kind of excited to see
him back in action
um as he faces jeffrey john yeah a very
nice
junior match up there i like it and
break down the prizes for his chip
150 000 at stake here including 40k for
first
everybody walking away with at least
four thousand dollars
and there's a nice differentiation every
single prize
very nice thank you st louis chess club
thank you rex and jeannie
for their very generous sponsorship and
there we're getting to see
our latest uh rendition of our v
chess jen oh yeah beautiful and i like
how the purple
clouds match like some of the lighting
in iacarro's new studio he said
you know this is his new tsm studio that
he's
recording in and it looks really cool
and the v chess
you have these like wooden pieces um i
love how
they keep tweaking it to look a little
bit different but the big question is
what is the opening that's gonna appear
on this v chess board momentarily as
it's almost two o'clock
well lanier one of our very best
uh prepared players uh even
fabiano tipped his hat and said yeah
lanier
uh you come and join my team uh when i
go up against magnus carlson for the
world championship now lanier has been
pretty consistently an e4 player
and very quickly hikaru
responded e5 and the berlin you know
everybody's favorite at the very top
maurice
yes not at the top of the commentary
world we might
no no no not in our world but
certainly this opening is so much
solidity the players are quite happy to
debate this position
especially hikaru cara says you know
what i'm probably not going to lose this
i know the ins and the outs unless
lanier has some kind of
big time novelty and where we're yet to
see something that cracks the
berlin wall hikaru plays this simply
all the time absolutely and it's been a
wonderful defensive
opening for the top players and
i'll be very curious to see what
lanier's approach will be
by the way an early night e7
there are lots of ways that black can
approach
this particular moment there's a5
there's h5 there's bishop e7
uh just simply a lot of moves and icaru
more or less he's been staying with the
h7h5
continuation so this 97
it's it's slippery it's it may not have
been exactly what
lanier prepared for but having said that
a2a4 came super fast like
right back at you he's got a plan in
mind
it'd be very fascinating to see how this
one develops as lanier is saying i got
something prepared here
and it's it's hard to figure out new
things in this variation
of course but the players have to
struggle with it because if you're going
to play
bishop b5 on move three you've got to
have something against this very direct
and straightforward knight of six which
used to be bad
back in the olden days but it's the main
line in modern chess
by the way yes sir i'm going to go to a
position where i'm not even going to
touch it i'm going to say
i need yasarawan to evaluate this one
for me and it's between the youngsters
jeffrey zhang
and awanda liang the two sub 20 year
olds
in the group in addition to the third
sam sevillan
but on move four is really where i want
you to go
back up to this move four and i got to
say
in this position after d5 b4 comes as a
surprise to my eyes please
give us your positional explanation of
the importance
of this move right at this moment
it's it's funny i'm i know it more
so in this position
when um oops uh yeah i think i
i think i've got it right uh the it's
it's essentially aimed at grunfell
players
greenfield players so hold on how how am
i gonna get in
the the move order i wanna i want yeah
let's say i want this move this move
this move this move grunfeld players
oftentimes play c7 c5
more or less against any type of setup
you throw at them
so the move b2b4 is
really a notion of saying to a groomfelt
player i just simply want to shut you
down
no more c7 c5 now
it now doing it in this particular move
order is
rather a bit of a wrinkle for me i'm not
that familiar with it
in this moment when the bishop is
staying behind
the structure usually the bishop is out
before you play b4 now having said
that uh you got to do something and if
you're in jeffrey's shoes
you may not want to take a wonder
right through the most theoretical lines
and play
something a little bit offbeat b2b4
maybe it fits that bill uh but
definitely an unusual
uh approach by jeffrey earley speaking
of
youngsters let's take a look at sam
seveon's battle
against various
new to our tournament as darius a very
high rated player got in by rating
slu student and he's here playing
um the main line of the session i've had
you know i feel like we don't see this
as much as you would think because it's
obviously such a great opening but maybe
it's just the repertoires of the people
in our events
like i think that i i haven't seen as
many of these and of course white
sometimes avoids it
by meeting knight c6 on the second move
with bishop b5 right
exactly the rossolimo right but you're
absolutely right when you think about
the london world championship match how
competitive
it was and how those games
in this feshnikov went they were really
rich
games and well obviously all all the
games were drawn but
magnus seemed to have better chances
with the black pieces at times
than he had with the white pieces you
would have thought that well the top
players would have
picked up the baton and ran with it a
bit but you're right
for some strange reason i'm not sure
what it is why it is
uh the top players have not
endorsed this variation
now what do we have here after knight f6
an invitation
to really mix it up uh take
taking i'm presuming now we've got one
of those situations that we just love
imbalances of four versus two on the
king side in favor of black
four versus two on the favor of the
queen side
with white but
these pawns are no i'm just going to say
pretty well blockaded we could imagine a
knight sinking in here in the bishop on
c5
which probably means white isn't that
interested
in trading early and releasing this
bishop to c5
square sooner or later whether you play
king h1 now or later
you're likely to play with the move c2
c4
intriguing approach by
um players
yeah take a look at this game between
another first timer
timer elsian muradiabadi
and sam shanklin mm-hmm and
elshon uh got to a solid position with
the white pieces
right out of the opening and on move
eight the most c5 is pawn sacrifice
which we consider
a typical break for black as he tries to
get some play
but it allows a capture and on the
capture
you would expect something in the
direction of that pawn now you've taken
let me go get do something a knight
attack it may be a
d7 or a6 or some kind of move
in that they're a queen attack it
something like that instead
the complete other side of the board
knight to f4 was played
what a fantastic move like what that's
so flamboyant looking
and so disconnected from your last move
that you say
what's the logic here
his pawn at all you sack on c5 to play
knight f4
i mean i see the knight is definitely
restraining that bishop on f1
it is eyeing the d3 square as well so g2
and d3 under fire and you can't
guard this c pawn easily as we know move
like b4
you always drop your c pawn on c3 that
is the back one
if you ever play b4 to that laser bishop
action so that's
nothing he's worried about so he's
figuring you know what i'll pick my pawn
up
later later but for now what is this
night alone at night by the way creating
disruption in the position
bishop g3 played aggressing this night
saying why are you even here
get out and sam played another curious
move
queen c7
accepting this pin how many of us would
do that
i'm not happy to accept the pin this
move is
is even more bizarre than knight f4
because like knight before you can
think like okay they're trying to play
knight d3 check and like
you know stop you from castling or force
you to make some concessions to castle
but like
queen c7 actually disallows you from
playing knight d3
puts you in a pin you can't even play
queen take c5 yet because bishop takes
f4
exactly now granted i'm not i'm not
criticizing sam here because it's
obvious he prepared this
right like it's just like it's
definitely like chess from the moon like
you see
i i love that description this is some
serious outer space chest going on
by the way i had an instinct to play
queen a4 and attack that night like what
is it doing on an f4
you try to give it up but he could play
a move like e5
or g5 and just defend it and say what
are you doing you're doing nothing e5 is
probably the best way to do it
and so meaningless and i'm still back on
the c pawn
amazing crazy chess in this
three three a span of three moves c5
knight f4 and queen c7 like that's just
we i i would never have played those
moves well c5 i might but not knight if
we're inquisitive
but i guess the point is just that it's
like you're restricting white because we
we need to castle
right clearly we can't just not castle
forever i mean we have a lot of students
who try that but it doesn't usually work
out so well
so we can't not castle but the problem
is the bishop on f1
if we move it knight g2 check and bishop
f4 queen f4
if we get our pawn back on c5 with no
issues then guess what sam just grabbed
the two bishops and is
just going to be better with black so um
it's it kind of is curious here like how
how would you deal with this with
white like can you try something like
queen size queen c2 and castle's long
not really because there's bishop f5 in
your face
suggested by maurice makes more sense
but i'm not perhaps
we have seen bishop f4 queen f4 on the
board dead chin
yeah so he decided that it was paramount
to just get the bishop out in castle and
i don't blame elisha
but i'm not happy if i'm white this guy
just put some fancy moves in my face
you know c5 got a break got my bishop
from me now
with this knight f4 business and it
looks like the c pawn is
going to be dead soon i mean knight
attacks it somehow
knight d7 a natural one and you can't
play b4
if you play knight b3 you block that
square
and so
i mean you blocked the b pawn from
advancing so it looks like
black is just fine by the way a rook is
going to end up on d8
as well to aggress this queen
if black gets a 97 has been played
black gets two or three moves as white
i'm thinking
what happened well i think you have to
play queenie too
uh otherwise if you just go
you know like uh jen you say you know
you want to play castles but if you just
go
castles knight takes e5 black is just
for choice he's got the two bishops in a
fine game no problem so i'm thinking
queenie two
is definitely going to be elshon's
choice so his
idea is he defends the bishop which
makes
the move knight b3 possible so you can
defend the pawn
while attacking the pawn on e7 in other
words if you defend the pawn on e7
or you push the pawn on e7 you give me
the time i need
to play knight to b3 and maybe on a good
day i'll just
maintain the pawn for a long while um
on the other hand if something like this
starts to get ultra sharp the queen
you know i mean you know there is a king
but
the queen takes e7 does come with the
tempo
it does hit the knight so it's not just
play on one goal you can't go
bishop g4 and rookie eight next uh
because the knight is hanging so
things and by the way queenie e2 on the
board
and e6 e7 e6 so okay
uh even though we've lost the two
bishops it's like as
white elshon is actually kind of saying
okay
i did something i did something that was
very concrete and very good
i robbed that bishop of a very good
diagonal and i
made it that much weaker now in this
position
i'm not 100 sure you you mentioned it
maurice that you know when you play
knight b3 you step in front of the pawn
on uh b2 the pawn on b2 can never
go to b4 when the knight's sitting on b3
so for that reason
i might want to play knight to e4 uh
the idea is obviously i'm defending this
pawn then i'm also eyeballing this
the the d six square sorry and
i want to play b4 after i've castled so
the jury's still out on
who's got the upper hand coming out of
the opening but a very
uh unusual one and um
this this game looks like it could be a
real a real
uh fun one knight e4 and
is is there a clear way for black to
play after this
queen c7 looks like the only way to go
get
that pawn back because your pieces are
growing
in intensity there's no question about
it white's looking
far more coordinated although going
after that bishop
yeah you could if you want to say well i
want my two bishops back but you do lose
right two moves in order to do it you
played
in fact you played 94 knight d6 and
tates for bishop that's just casually
sitting back there going
well i wasn't doing anything in fact i
was trying to figure out how am i going
to get into the game
but thanks for the free moves
what i was going to do now okay so here
you know i'm free i'm feeling the spirit
of frank marshall
you know somehow kind of weirding me out
since the night isn't on on f6
i start to look at ideas of h4 so
uh but i need to castle as well so let
me start with
queen e3 uh so that something like b7 b6
right
just uh just to have some fun and
let's go let's just go h4
and and frank marshall would do this to
players right
you know it takes h5 takes
h6 and you know
he bamboozled more people
you'd never expect would be bamboozled
but he got a number of it
now of course you were very compliant
you didn't
play knight takes e5 but i'm just saying
that uh
with the missing knight on f6 well all
of that is for naught
after e6 the players actually just a
second let me go back and forth sorry
uh all for naught after queen e2
knight b3 castles al-shawn just said
okay you've got the two bishops but i'm
the first on the d-file
i feel i like i like your nike six
knight c8 idea better i'm just worried
about
like b6 and bishop b7
and six bishop b7 very natural for life
well one of the things that i mean for
those of you and again a big shout out
to audience thank you so much for
joining us
one of the things that we have said time
and time and time again on all of our
broadcasts
when you have the two bishops
one of the things that your opponent
should try to do
is deny you the two bishops when you
play b7 b6 against me i know
i know i know it's not like the greatest
thing i've ever done
but i want to rob you of your two bishop
advantage so
i would probably play bishop a6 before
the bishop lands on b7
and better squares and sam agreed that's
why he started with a6 because he wants
the right and then bishop b7 which is
what
much better incarnation right now you
might wonder well
what if white plays a4 but then there's
a couple things first of all b6 doesn't
hang upon on a6
anymore no yeah um so so also didn't
even try to avoid it he just started
with the move rookie one
okay um look f1 now that's a big
surprise for me
uh normally speaking i'm trying to to
out
maneuver out strategize my opponent so
i'm thinking how clever i am i see that
bishop wants to come to b7 you
thwarted my desire when the move a7 a6
was
played you thwarted my desire to trade
bishops
so i'll try it again i'll go bishop d3
anticipating b5 so that you could and
then i'll put my bishop here
and then i'll double my rooks on the
d-file
al-shawn just said no i can live with
everything you're doing
rookie one beef oop excuse me b5 by sam
bishop d3 and al-shaan is saying yeah if
you put your bishop on b7
i'll play bishop d3 and i'm rock solid
as white
but not an ambitious line of play for
for el shawn either though
let's take a look at one of our favorite
people in the world
works with us on the broadcast and is
now got
to play in this tournament again he had
a great result years ago
when we tied for a second he had a
playoff against godakomski
and it's none other than alejandro
ramirez in the house now we get to see
the player side
in the u.s championship and he looks
like he has a decent position
against ray robson this is something
like ray's
13th or 14th championship in a row
i mean he's he's got the standing record
i believe
is what i heard from our
resident guru ed gonzalez who
knows everything about the u.s
championship and i mean this guy
ray robson he still looks like a baby
and he's been playing in so
many of these in a row one of america's
finest players
indeed look at the opening i like this
way
alejandro played and it must be theory
you see this idea
e5 knight f5 d5
and then the sacrifice potentially of
the b-pawn which would have given black
full compensation by the way as he took
on d5
and then bishop takes f5
followed by d take c6 queen c7
i don't need to weaken my paw structure
you can have my stinking b7 pawn
if you want to queen takes b7 will be
played with
great play on the queen side and the
bishop on f1 has a
tough time getting to the game because
that queen on b7
is going to hit along that entire long
diagonal
from b7 all the way to g2 so taking on
b7 ray said
no mega stop i'm not interested i'm just
going to keep developing my pieces
but one more tempo is alejandro was
insistent
i'm going to keep this position going
now with an e4 threat
and queen had to move yet again and only
now capture
on c6 what's wrong with black's position
here i see a rook is going to end up on
the c
file and potentially gain another tempo
on that queen but if i can get in bishop
e7 in castles
i can't feel bad for black that pawn on
d3 looks weak
absolutely it looks like a a
um opening gone wrong in fact uh
for white as safe
king good developed pieces effective
pieces good pawn structure no targets by
black
no uh ray definitely got outfoxed
in a very uh cunning way uh
by alejandro now here you know
white is kind of playing some kind of a
mixed
uh system of the english attack against
the
taimanov um gee i don't even know how to
describe it
uh but after the move queen d2 you know
we're expecting
typically moves like queen c7 and bishop
b4
perhaps even d7 d6 with this move e5
maybe this is the latest and greatest
wrinkle but this move knight f5
it went south i mean i just don't
i just don't see that move as a very
good move
uh ray may have been much better off
just dropping back with his knight
i've seen a number of occasions where
white wants to play h3 and g4 when the
knight
especially gets kicked back to e2 as we
saw it in the game
it all went beautiful and this move
queen c7
maybe this is what ray missed the the
strength of this move and you mentioned
that maurice
you take your pawn up you congratulate
yourselves a lot
like well done until you start to say
well wait a minute wait a minute
pawn on b2 is hanging pawn on g2
is hanging no i'm not particularly
thrilled about
castling into an attack where my
opponent's already
tickling c2 i mean no no
jennifer jennifer immediately reacted
not that you know her attacking self
came out quick
like oh man what you just castled
right into my attack are you crazy i
don't
have excited seeing that boy halloween
is coming up but the inner
gen nearly manifested itself like just
like let me let me get on my gloves
though ray didn't want any parts of that
position whatsoever
another player who uh has won
u.s championships and is a big
threat whenever you talk about rapid
chess wesley so one of the top players
in the world
he's up against alex lenderman alex
coming into this competition
um i want to say he he did it by
raiding he he outraged
some really top guys to get here
but alex has been one of those very
quiet players he
represents the u.s on occasion but
we don't hear too much from him he was a
captain
um when the us team won gold right so
that was
that was a huge boom for him over john
donaldson you mean
no coach i'm sorry he was a coach not
the captain yes
international master john donaldson was
the captain and alex linderman was the
coach so
um a pretty big achievement for him
there is in in baku
but uh just the fact that the players
because it is the players the players
picked
lenderman as a coach that's that's your
sign of respect right there when
when it's your peers saying i want that
guy
you know working with me and we
a big time move was just played uh b6 b5
because basically what that move means
is that you split your pawns uh so you
really
have compromised your structure but
you've done it for very specific
reasons of dynamic play your rook now
lords over the d file there's no rook d2
knight e4 hurt your feelings
you would allow bishop d3 bringing you
back to um we're bringing you back to c1
and i i've been i'm nervous about um how
much white is getting pushed back here
with rook v8 exactly 94 is always in
play
so you might go rook e1 right away just
sidest so like that action that we just
saw
down the b file i mean you're right a
rook has been pushed away from the
defense of the pawn
um but this move b b5 is
basically say hey look i'm not just
gonna wait around and
pretend i'm equal or something like that
i want to force the action and he's
forced the action and by the way
a better move than what is suggested
wesley played rook
e5 um you're not
immediately threatening to take the pawn
because uh
taking the pawn walks into the night
fork but rookie fight by wesley on the
board
bishop c6 and and
alex is one of those players who
actually
you don't see him coming but he actually
plays really quite
rapidly he he he stays with you
on the clock wesley's one of the faster
uh rapid chess
time control players he usually wesley
manages to build up uh time on the clock
but he hasn't
like uh alex has stayed with him bishop
c6 by the way
threatens rook b8 i tried bishop c4 just
to
sidestep rook b8 uh what do you guys
make of this position
good good play for the
for the damage structure or what do you
think yes that b
file is concerning me i don't want to
defend and
the knight looks like he has squares as
well at night thinking about e4
at some point knight d8 could always
chase the rook out and didn't go to b6
i don't know it just feels like black is
very dynamic here
doesn't mean that he's in any way
winning but
i mean not even i'm not even giving an
advantage but i don't like the b-pawn as
a weakness i just feels like
a move like a4 followed by rook to b8
and you might have to take up a
defensive posture in this position and
both sides will have weaknesses
yeah yeah that seems like a very strong
move
a4 and vorusian agrees black has a very
small plus i'd still say that
with wesley's um stellar defensive
skills
the highest chances for this game is a
draw but
yeah after this money move a4 rook v8 is
annoying
and white's pieces are just more awkward
than blacks
upon like f4 where you know that's
really nice sometimes in a middle game
giving you access to the e5 square
can really come back to haunt you in the
end game where it creates some
weaknesses
um so nicely played by lenderman getting
off to a good start and
playing black against the number one
rated player in the competition
wow let's make sure one let's make sure
he
uh still survives this game though
before we say
good start and good opening good good
end game set up to be sure
good opening middle game and early in
the end game
good time management too very important
but boy you crash and burn in the game
and suddenly a good start could feel
like
like nothing special you got a good
position and just got outplayed speaking
of getting outplayed
take a look at the young jeffrey zhang
about to turn 20 years old the day after
this championship ends
so he won't be a baby anymore he's going
to be double
uh he's going to be two of the big two
ago
and so okay but for now he's still a
teenager
and he's trying to give the true teen
a lesson in this game one de liang and
one of the most important moves
in chess we saw earlier bishop takes
night
this opening went crazy after we saw the
early b4 so we could back up and show
how this got here all right we see it
wonder decided to
challenge this pawn with a5 and jeffrey
said no problem kid
i can play b5 and c5 and now that b-pawn
is a restrictive
force on that square he cemented it with
a4
and as they went ahead jeffrey played uh
jeffrey played a nice move in just a
couple of moves he said
you can have a break i can too with the
move c4 and
that led him to play this exchange on c5
and that's the move i was talking about
bishop takes on c5 a hyper critical move
in this moment to say you can have the
two bishops
i don't care i'm going to crack your
pawn structure
isolate your c-pawn as well as establish
a pass b-pawn for myself and don't
forget you also have
an isolated a5 pawn now this is
the exact same isolated uh the same two
pawns that jeffrey has
not jeffrey uh alex has linderman has
uh against wesley but this is a very
different position
here here you've got a blockade for the
moment at least with the knight on b6
but that c pawn can be blockaded well
and knight c4
played again trying to apply pressure
and getting to that
end game where that b-pawn will be a
force
interesting position good decisions by
jeffrey so far i like this move knight
c4
a lot i also like following it up
with knight on f3 to d2 a lot
the idea there is also to put a bishop
on f3
one of the things i discovered like
i almost became a chess master i think
it was just slightly before that time
that um i i was enamored
completely totally in love with fee and
shadow bishops
and i really praised them to the skies
and i thought that you know like when i
had
my fianchetto bishop on this long
diagonal
you know raking my opponent's position
that i was really
pleased with myself and i thought i
always had an advantage
thanks to the fact i had this great
bishop well my opponent one day
um had a pawn on b5 and a knight on c4
and it was basically that dark squared
bishop versus that
knight on c4 and the dark square bishop
actually did nothing
once those pawns get to b5 and there's
no c
pawn for this bishop to snack upon it's
really like a great defensive bishop
defending the king i mean but it doesn't
really have any offensive punch now this
move knight d2
to f3 on the other hand especially when
the bishop was back here on b7
if i were white i would love to play the
move knight d2 bishop f3
exchange off the bishop and get to that
position of knight versus bishop
and that's where jeffrey is heading now
likelihood
is we may get a bishops of opposite
color positions
but in that case the spawn on b5 is more
useful
than this pawn on c5 so to my mind
advantage jeffrey in one of those
weird subtle ways uh a wonderliang has
been outplayed
a big development in the game with jeff
with
no it's l shot no i i lost the chance
i was going to no it was alejandro
excuse me my apologies yes i've been
bouncing around and ray robson
and and i no i just kept talking even
though i was looking at another position
so i got confused that said i'm back
it's
alejandro with the with the black pieces
against ray and
alejandro decided to sack a pawn
he said bishop g5 i'm just going to
castle
you can have this pawn if you want you
could have played h6 for example or
some kind of move to to test his
opponent but he said nah i'm just going
to
castle you can have the pawn put a
worker knee
and you just took a pawn i mean
okay that's weird
you normally you kind of like those
pawns especially
pretty good i mean you know in our poll
uh our grandmaster pole uh 10 out of 10
grand masters say they do like pawns
uh queen h3 okay
well ray is basically saying okay um
i've got the extra pawn show me the
compensation
and after knight d5 i actually
like alejandra's position i thought he
was slightly better before he sacrificed
the pawn
now i think he's got great compensation
but not better anymore
well weird right the thing about this
position is
it's going toward liquidation he will
likely make this d-pawn
not that not that serious it's already
it looks pretty bad on d3 by the way
but you'll neutralize this pawn pretty
readily we may see a massive number of
trades in the position
but what will he win back he'll win the
d-pawn if he wins anything right right
you can have the d-pawn and if you do
win the d-pawn what's the remaining
position of the minor pieces off the
board
it's equal he's not playing for better
maybe he was never better
but here he's certainly looking to just
equalize the position get that d-pawn
back and he better get the d-pawn back
by the way guys
because ray will be thinking about how
to keep it and bug him
seriously even here the move knight e4
had to be considered but rager simply
captured on e7 decided
not to get crazy in any way he played
this move
i guess he's he was worried a knight
might end up on f4 at some point
and here you see the d-pawn may or may
not drop
uh but white has to be careful black
doesn't get some activity while you're
being too greedy trying to keep this
pawn
but this game should be drawn it looks
like he's happy to neutralize the
position down
and it looks like black will have enough
compensation to to
to make it a draw which will be a good
result for alejandra with the black
pieces against one of the best players
in the country
yeah question about it let's go back to
our marquee matchup
between a lanier dominguez and
hikaru after a very standard position
knight e7 uh an older old-time mover
uh arthur bisguire used to love to play
the berlin and he would play it with
knight e7 and he did it with a very sp
specific aim which was to put his knight
on g6
so that his bishop could come to f5
a4 came very quickly and i must say
that this expansion on the queen side
it's a bit of a surprise bishop g4
pinning the knight
and no problem said linear let me
continue with a5 um
potential for a rover and after knight
g6 yep we saw it rook came up
uh tempo against the bishop okay you can
take
you can't take this pawn on e5 that
would be
one cookie too many as oops
black will lose a piece to either rookie
four or rookie one
pinning the knight to the king so after
takes takes
bishop e7 now the thread is genuine
hence f4 f5 now here we can imagine that
hikaru would love to
maneuver the knight to the beautiful
blockading square e6
so then linear says nope
not going to let you do it ampersand
and well not a great structure
but more development for white and again
don't forget that black's
king has been compromised it cannot
castle move like castles might be very
good
can't do it rook d8 okay that says
that's an important trade right there uh
i'm i was thinking that uh
lanier might try to keep some pieces on
the book
keep his rooks on the board with the
move rookie one he traded
and my inclination would have been to
avoid this because i can see
the rook coming to the e file but now we
understand why he played
a5 that is a genuine weakness it's not
like
uh you know white does really want to
take it he wants to take this bishop he
wants to take that pawn
and you can't play b6 and trap the
bishop thanks to the pawn being on a5
and don't slap yourself if you wanted to
play bishop takes b2
because that would really be injurious
after rook b4
white's rook is the one penetrating the
opponent's camp so
b7 b6 and after all of that
guess what the open a file lands in
white's lab
who would have thunked it and i'm just
wondering how much of this might be
um preparation by linear i i have an
awesome respect for his prep this is
this is some high level stuff guys is it
enough though
as i'm looking at this position is it
enough to
i mean king's going to rookie on e8
kane's on a d7 i think white's idea is
very straightforward
he's going to take on this bishop he's
definitely going to take this bishop
and he's going to make that pawn a dark
square so that
he can go bishop f6 king f3
king g4 and go right after that pawn
now what i've been looking at is
obviously
grabbing the pawn but here i think the
bishop
actually can get trapped after
c3 and the rook is ready to come back
you can give up the exchange
for the pawns
maybe maybe that's that's a hard one to
judge
man that is tough indeed rook takes e4
and bishop c3 in that position
yeah that's crazy and you see you see
hikaru there
thinking about it because that is one
and maybe two pawns that that was
actually the move i thought you were
going to mention yes
is knight as a knight g5 timely move
if you could if you could get it quickly
maybe even immediately but it doesn't
seem to lead anywhere
yeah exactly maurice the thing is is
it's nice if you're
if you're making some kind of a four
sequence where you got to go knight f7
to e5 check and you
i don't know you you fork a bishop you
pick up a pawn with check
but i'm just thinking it's a kind of
vacuous threat
in 96 and knight f7 not really
interfering with anybody so i came to c3
came to look at rook here and if you if
hicaru sacrifices the exchange for
three connected past pawns who can blame
him right
indeed well take a look at the explosion
that's happened
jeffrey zhang and awanda liang as
queen c2 we got this position
and jeffrey said i don't believe you
give me the pawn i want to know why
can't i take
it you can maybe play a rook to a8 but
i don't believe you what what does
jeffrey have in mind
i guess the c pawn on on c5 is hanging
and how can you play that and actually
after rook a8 he
immediately played knight to c4 knight
d 1974 right right
okay at the moment the the knight is
protected
and very quickly a wonder captured
and we do have this position on the
board now the question is
can we take and sure if we could get a
knight
c3 and start hitting some people but
i'm thinking jeffrey is the first to
land some blows here
bishop f3 in alabama
and you've got seven you've got to
disconnect your rooks
i know it's not something you
necessarily wanted to do look at that b6
move we all want to play i know i know
okay you play it you overworked that
queen somehow but it
didn't seem possible there but i feel
there's something wrong that bishop
guarding and we do see a trade instead a
rook takes d1 trade
happen instead of allowing white to make
the trade
i think it's kind of transposes if we
if we recapture with the rook right so
we're
we're maintaining eye contact with the
knight
the rook is hanging which means you've
got to play rook a7
now i hear you guys loud and clear that
b6 is like you know
over here you know pass me the ball
uh i don't quite see it not unless i'm
getting rook to yaden
i can imagine bishop c6 but don't forget
i've got a back rank made issue myself
and the highly desirable rook d7
is going to fall afoul of rook a1 so
rook d6 instead threaten b6 again oh
okay there's still a back rank mate
right
well there's always
to stop that from being as powerful yeah
well this is a weird one guys i think
yeah uh this this there's a kind of a
gummy
a piece is going on normally speaking
you think
aha i got you i'm gonna easily win
here but this pawn is a remark
strangely enough going home now what's
the story here though
here i'm threatening a discovered
checkmate
and yeah that one and the queen no by
the way
that defends the bishop so yeah we don't
like that
yeah uh that's why but hold on hold on
there's a rook a6 move that stops the
mate
uh when you play knight two that's
important stop the mate with if you can
get a pass
a pawn we'll take this on as well as
that's you
coupon that bishop is guarding the a8
square so
yeah i mean it's huge uh
this be it it's remarkable how much
stronger the b5 pawn
is as a past pawn versus the c5 pawn
it's like that extra square up the board
means i'm obviously i'm closer to
promoting than you are but
uh thanks to the space that extra half
ply that tempo and these threats this is
nice for white rook d6 that might be the
the money move i was about to recommend
you know in view of those back rank mate
issues you start with g3
because well you get out of the bank
mate
and none of these threats are are going
away but
maybe rook d6 uh
accelerating the action is the way to go
did i do it wrong with knight b2 maybe i
should have played
knight b6 sorry yes uh maurice he did
play rook d6 by the way on the board
jeffrey with the most aggressive move
contentious looking for the win
guys i will say if you bounce around the
three the horn
knight e3 if you bounce around the horn
it looks like maybe a slight edge for
white in
in one position or two but
it looks equal everywhere except here
except here
except here here's the wildest game this
might be the only decisive game if
jeffrey manages to win because
everything else looks equal
equalish i mean it's incredible a solid
start to the championship we expect more
explosive games of course
but here we go knight c3
be blindfold there's a check on the back
ring that will disrupt things
okay right and so
on why why doesn't this fall for that
same what trick that we've seen we were
looking we were what about rook do you
want instead of bishop d1 yes
no no question we've got to play work d1
instead
but now i take oh and then just take
and just take because you can always
block that should be one yeah wow wait a
second
or even queen do you want
but this is so gonna hold on so
wait a minute okay tell me what's going
on here
well i just need to deflect your rook
for you to resign right because
you're working resign you're not you're
not playing double check
i could play queen a6 where x yeah
queen a8 queen a6 i just need to deflect
your rook that's insane
that's a fun finale though and then it's
like it's really bad that your bishop
ended up on f8 because
exactly you could play rook a1
okay what at the end it's amazing that
the rook ended up deflected but we do
have oh wait this is the current
situation v6 played
i don't know but but even 51. by the way
by the way knight d2 i didn't have to
give up the queen either i could play
knight d2
instead of instead of giving up the
queen for nothing
so what did we try so a moment ago i
tried to
take the rook with the knight and lose
my queen but
that pawn made it in a tortoise-like
fashion all the way up the board and
promoted
but a wonder is in trouble because
unfortunately he doesn't have the
desirable queen a7 simply defending the
rook
that square is not available so
did a wonder get he hasn't calculated
he has to accept this b-pawn which looks
unacceptable he has to take on d1
and move his queen back
rook takes d1 check bishop takes and
then move your queen
to b8 or yeah someplace active even
right but then and then say can i get my
knight back
to d5 and bug you and
somehow that bishop on g7 is terrible
i mean just it's terrible and that's
that
that that really exemplifies the comment
i was making
earlier that you know you you're so
proud of yourself that you've got this
great
knowledge and understanding about
fianchetto bishops
and then you come to this amazing dead
end where
the bishop turns out to be anemic simply
a non-factor
and in a position like this bishop f3
let me just put some moves on the board
exemplify is what i mean this was
strangely enough is actually
doing something very important after b7
bishop takes t5 that night
could get eliminated this bishop on the
other hand
maybe maybe maybe on a good day will
actually
play a role in the defense but for the
moment
it it's amazing how it's
a non-factor it's just like doesn't
does it doesn't have a role and a wonder
in this current position
is coming to some harsh realizations
he's worse yeah this is the game
this may be the only win which is
super surprising this may be the only
win of the round unless somebody
blunders
on another board because you can just go
around the horn
maybe the most interesting game is the
one between the year and
yes ikaru as pawns are trying to fly up
the board
it does look as though b4 is on
more or less unstoppable
and it was a crazy bishop
bishop ending uh b4 is unstoppable
i'm sorry maurice yes continue the i was
saying
if i can get a b4 and trade bishops then
white will
have to respect those pawns because c5
will follow
so because of that
lanier said i'm not i'm not going
anywhere i'm bringing my king back
i need to help out in the fort but not
on the ranch
i need to help out elson our first
result is in
el shawn and sam have drawn their game
very good draw by el shawn after that
exotic opening by sam
so that one we saw the pieces get
hoovered the rooks especially dropped
from the board and then once the queen
left after queen d6
there was not much extra to do here and
peace broke out relatively quickly
quite an interesting game
a game very very worthy of a classical
chess game
didn't see many didn't see any errors by
the
players uh they certainly played
well-played
yeah just a good game a king d3
on the board by lanier well i mean let's
we know this should be drawn yes okay
this this should be more or less equal
we need to see the other game because
the queen sack
variation did happen he did give up his
queen and now there's a pawn on c7
okay and we know we have a defense with
with a
with 93 bishop d1 played
and what is he counting on how can this
possibly be okay
he played knight c2 um but
the bishop d1 he didn't take the bishop
right and he played 92 hitting the
bishop on d1 threading checkmate and if
knight e3
knight takes e3 right and we could have
we would have a rook and a piece and a
couple pawns for the queen
but jeffrey immediately played this move
queen to d8
and defending his bishop and freezing
everything there's no now what there's
no
nothing nice there's a knight but then
there's 993 there was knight b2 on the
last move wasn't it maybe two or 93 yeah
they both work you can get even if
you've got a piece i get like if you got
a piece back you'd feel okay for sure
you just have to work for a queen which
is right now it's just a rook for a
queen and you're not getting anything
back
you have a working and two pawns but
yeah it's it's clearly not enough
because those pawns are just
all the way back on the board not not
any pawns that are
creating worries for white white is he
just played king g7 by the way
and h4 threatening to just move that
king
well there goes our back rank problems
yeah i mean still have knight e3
no problem this is over this is going to
be the first win
and jeffrey may take the sole lead in
the event
many of the other games are looking very
dry birds
got so many games in progress maurice
you never know yeah these
these these guys i trust them and these
at least in these positions i i'm gonna
say i'm
i trust them although we do we have seen
stranger things in time pressure
so let's take a look if we can find a
little bit of potential pressure on
alejandro as rey's king is on the fifth
rank and
alejandro's is on the sixth rank i mean
my you know what i'm saying the fourth
yeah miking is more advanced than yours
so if you run out of tempe
there could be issues right i mean yes
i agree if you have to play like b5 for
instance and then you lose a tempo when
i get into either e5 or c5
okay maybe you have a problem then
that's a lot of ifs though
and ray only has 30 seconds left on the
board
by the way that's something that we're
going to be talking a lot about
is raised time trouble i mean in
classical chess he's notorious
for running down and playing on his
increment
will we be seeing that ray robson in
this tournament answer
yes he likes it he likes being in time
trouble some people do
i hate it but some people thrive let's
see how
this is going or more they just they
they don't hate it they hate making
imperfect moves
more than they hate time pressure right
that's exactly one way of thinking like
they they really despise playing a bad
move
so much so that they'd rather spend 20
minutes and play
not so bad like the logic doesn't really
work in the end of the day but
the thing is some people just love chess
and it's not just about
they're maximizing the result it's like
they get sucked into this world
and you know in some ways you have to
admire that even if it hurts their
competitive over the borders all it's
it's kind of wander with four
seconds by the way down to ten he's
still moving
awanda is still moving he's down a queen
for a rook and two pawns
and i think he's dreaming of a day when
maybe he can set up some kind of strange
blockade but
we don't believe it well done weird i
like this but
the blockade issue is like you got to
take get rid of my pun on h5
my point on h5 is such a factor because
i'm going to try to use it to create
um threats against you right checkmating
threats absolutely
that's going to be a bone in your throat
especially with eight seconds left in
the clock by the way
our top board between nakamura and
dominguez was a draw indeed
okay let's just quickly well no let's
not go there let
yeah we can uh just i wanted to one game
that we didn't
quite look at that much was sam sevillan
versus darius
uh that was the um sveshnikov and it's
come
down to what for all
uh appearances could be a standard
looking rook and pawn in game
but there's actually a lot of
traps and tricks that this ending
possesses one of them
is this threat of going rook e3 and
transposing at
any moment into a king upon end game
where you could use
this outside pawn as a decoy b7 b6
uh the last move there by daria says
he's looking
to stop this rook e3 and go into a king
and pawning game where he
wow i don't know this is funny how would
you evaluate this
kingpin game after this move because i
can
always use my queen side as a decoy
right
but on the other hand
i could find myself stuck i have to play
a move like
h4 and
the king is in the square yeah the
problem is in order to use the b-pawn as
a decoy you've got to allow him to have
an a-pawn
right oh hey a bigger decoy so right
winning that looks impossible a blunder
in the game
with jeffrey and awander ended the hopes
off
the blockade as he dropped a rook to a
queen check
a wander losing at the end
as this check the retreating move
i love retreating moves strong players
often miss these types of moves
and here we go instead of playing bishop
f8 he brought his king up and
check gifted me the rook yes that was
the end of that defense
it didn't look like that he was going to
be jeffrey jumps
wesley wesley better all of a sudden
according to varusian who's been
watching this game definitely
as also alex linderman is on the
pressure on the clock remember earlier
we said that that pawn on a4
gave black activity against the b-pawn
right so
earlier white was kind of pushed back
and we had more active pieces but here's
the flip side
if that activity doesn't result in
anything white
is going to be worse because of the
split pawns black is going to be worse
you're absolutely right
now here we have the bishops of opposite
color and the most important feature
is the fact that these two pawns the
pawns on a4 and f5
are on light squares so in a dream world
white would want to put his bishop on c6
as well as d7
so from d7 you're hitting both pawns
uh you might think that okay
you could also in a dream world put your
bishop on c2
but then the bishop will go to d7 right
so
here if you could put the bishop on d7
force the black bishop
to c2 then you have a tempo
like c3 c4 how do you do it
yeah it feels like this could be one of
those
winning bishop endings thanks to a
zukzwang
uh situation alex slenderman in trouble
here
i i hear you the only problem is the
only problem is that
when you get bishop what is it bishop d7
or bishop c2 i i would say i start with
bishop d1
and i go to e8 okay i'm just going to
wait for you to get to your point
right so here's what i was saying so d7
so now in this position you have to make
a
move that compromises yourself as well
this is this is the point c4h5 hangs one
of your pawns
right that puts that makes me put one of
my pawns on the light square the
difference though is
is i'm the one dictating that reaction
though maurice
so let's say at this position you're in
zukzwang right now you have to go after
the h-bomb
so i'll take this guy this is the game
this has just happened and h5 is on the
board
right and i'll go bishop to d7
right and my
idea is of course i want to take a pawn
you know that already
but my deeper idea is i want to go f5
bishop e6 and f6
aren't i went oh wesley said
h7 is the dream square well the problem
was
the problem was bishop d sev and i think
it's going to be the same problem here
bishop d7 i think is meant by bishop d1
and if you play f5 i switch back and
play bishop g4
well that's my point where when i'm not
at
six years six sorry yeah right no no
when my bishop's not on e6 i go and and
look at that
uh in fact what happened was
the bishop the black bishop was not
going to be able
after wesley's bishop h7 to hold up the
pawn
recognizing this lenderman retreated
with his king
and oh brought his likings
great defense great defense
to get in into the square of the pawn
now he's got an h-bomb
that's right great defense beautiful
defense
well done by lindemann yes you got what
you could get out of it
but now it's my turn and your pawn's
going nowhere
you might get a pass b-pawn but the
bishop on h5 will handle your past
b-pawn or c-pawn
but in the meantime hello welcome to the
h party
is harry the name of both h pawns like
i know harry the h-pawn for white but it
seems like
if you're black you don't want the name
harry because harry is the eighth
the the white spawn right you want to be
hair rolled
like you want to be a herald not just a
harry
a harold i'm i'm going for hakeem
the dream like the team the dream the
language team the gym elijah won and
that h pawn
is a dream right now it's getting the
counter play for black as the pawn
flies down the board and says dwight
sorry you're not just queening
yourself you're gonna have to respect my
pawn as well
and exactly it looks very much like he
should be able to hold this now that
said
he can't afford to lose the c-pawn
without some kind of comp oh well this
this should be enough compensation
g2 is netting a piece and
it should be just fine for this bishop
and king
combination to draw this game well
that's right
by the way we gotta draw in ramirez's
game as well so indeed jeffrey zhang
looking like he will be the sole leader
after this game
well which game was it from one of our
earlier national championships
wasn't it a ladies game where where
uh one player forced the win of a piece
for some pawns
but then the pawns went through yeah i
remember how was that
talia is what i wanted to say yeah um
yeah and i'm just i i'm just seeing
echoes
of that u.s championship game where
you know somehow black bishop
never really uh froze the pawns now of
course
maybe it was annie versus jen
potentially i think jen
maybe was worse and then suddenly annie
overpressed and it was like a bunch of
pawns versus a knight or something
right something of that nature yeah well
here we see the king is actually
beautifully
blocking the the uh
defending king now obviously if your
defending king was on ce6 and your
bishop was on b5 it'd be no problem
but can we get there i think we can
it should be five just played whoa the
oh no did he blunder i'm sure he didn't
do
that bishop was on the wrong diagonal
people
his bishop is probably on the wrong
diagonal what else would you have played
there
that's confusing because now comes king
b7
and i think it's over that's what it is
that's exactly what it is he blew it he
should have been he should have
allowed himself to be able to play
bishop back
to b to g2 to stay on the diagonal
right yeah so you don't want to get up
close because then not only you get
tempted once by the king
but you know what guys really what he
needed was two minutes because
yes he was down on his clock or to have
studied the same game like
a week ago just by a fortune right
it seems a little bit weird no no not a
week ago a long time ago you've got to
put
end games like this in your pocket and
then reviewed it a week ago
like right yeah because i i no doubt
you know you probably studied it at some
point but if it's not fresh in your mind
playing it with
10 seconds left on the clock very very
difficult
and indeed wesley's so the second winner
of this round and i was just about the
same maurice you were right they were
all drawn
what a shocker huge blunder
and we know the blunders appear right
they appear in
in rapid chess and i'm going to i'm
going to push back jen i'm going to tell
you
these are these are the kind of endings
mark davareski wrote about this a while
back in his book tragic comedy or is it
a tragic comedy of chess or
or something tragic comedy was in the
title
and he talked about how it's so
important
to embed the end games in your core
that you need to know your end games
down and of course the basic ones alex
knows he can draw any
filler position et cetera vancouver
maneuver he's going to get all that
but these are the next level of
sophistication that you want to have in
your system as well
and you're not going to solve them at
the board
you cannot count on solving tricky
bishop versus extra pawns yeah that's
what i said though you got to know these
you've got to know them
when that that that was precisely what i
said though i said that if you're down
to 10 seconds you
better either have them you know
reviewed so many times that it's in your
court or having studied them like a week
ago
right yeah if i was i guess i was
pushing back on the week ago thing
because normally they don't do that they
don't go over
end games but you're right as far as
having the core
you've got to have these down because
you could even have two minutes on the
clock
and blunder we've seen people do this
over the board games
it's that's a tricky ending that a lot
of people don't look at
my instinct that said i mean i saw
bishop b5 i was like what are you doing
you've got to have your bishop to be
able to go back on that diagonal and
slow down the king i'm sure alex given
no pressure and maybe 20 more seconds to
reflect on the stuff he knows
he would have not put his mission on
that square i think he would have you're
right though
that's the thing like the 10 seconds you
kind of play purely on instinct and
you're afraid of the pawn going to c6 so
you put the bishop there
but um unfortunately the you really need
to split the pawns apart
so that you can take them one by one and
it's a yes it's a weird it's a weird
thing
and i i guess for everybody watching
this is a good moment for them to review
this end game
because maybe you'll save half a point
one day but alex did not save the half a
point and one of the favorites
gets the full point as nakamura and
dominguez drew their game
and let's watch the end of the most
convincing victory
of the round on v chess v
for victory in this case well at least
for jeffrey young
and he played a really precise tactical
game
to take this one home i've got to make
note
of the pawn on 68 exactly i just
witnessed a flaw in the program there is
a
white pawn on c8 and that was the pawn
that promoted
to a queen so that pawn should have been
eliminated it should have eliminated
itself
and it's funny it's not moving at all
either i know
that's supposed to be queen check that's
right
all right it's good it's good to have
some kind of
a feedback and i put white pawn on c8
the the programmers will
figure out that bug and fix it for sure
otherwise
beautiful ending by jeffrey not not the
best round if you're
if your initials are were a-l as alex
slenderman and dewander leong started
out with losses
but against two of the highest rated
players in the tournament
so there's plenty of game left for
alexander wander
wesley and jeffrey though starting off
with a bang
two of our higher rated players in the
competition
and i know we're gonna get our
predictions in real soon
so um guys turn your wheels but we're
gonna have
a little break and we will be back for
round two of the us chess championship
one of the things that absolutely makes
our sports
so unique is the extraordinary history
of chess chess in its modern form
is well over 500 years old and we have a
1500 year history that we can
reflect of i want to say and for me
when i look at what's going on at these
u.s championships i
know it's history in the making what are
some of your
favorite uh historical moments
in your career uh maurice i remember as
a young kid growing up in brooklyn
being influenced by these games from far
away places
with names that i never heard of i mean
funny
you know vikanze what is that where
is that right and then finally when i
got to go there myself
physically and and stand there and think
man i would have read about gary
kasparov's conquest
in these places and now i'm standing
here in in real time
so it's it's fascinating that chess does
that for us
it infects us with the love for me
particularly the love of traveling
and the world beyond its own 64 squares
that's right and even right now when we
can't
travel like we normally do there's these
opportunities for cross-cultural
discovery and friendships one of the
programs i'm doing
with the us chess women is we have
our girls from the united states do
joint classes with the
top girls in kenya and you can see these
kids on both sides haven't been
traveling a lot lately a lot of them
have been stuck at home
and it's a great joy to be able to meet
people from all over the world through
our game and to connect with them over
it
well i just love the an idea that
maurice had he'd come to hilversum
and i took him uh and said oh over there
then that building
that was where they played the great
avro tournament and memories was like
what
that was where avro was playing right
there in hilversum where's the plaque
i want to see a plaque and you can go uh
to a really wonderful hotel the
krasnopolski hotel
downtown amsterdam and that was where
alexander alakhine and max irva
played one of their world championship
match games from 1935
and maurice had this idea like where all
of these great historical
landmarks for chess took place there
ought to be
a feed a recognized historical bronze
plaque being placed
just like we did in saint louis we
unfurled that banner of the steiner
secretary match
this history is alive we've got to we
we've got to emphasize that more and
more
i'm glad you reminded me of that yes i
was i had such fun with you
as you took me to those places and you
saw us like a kid in a candy store
this is so amazing and
when you again you you read about these
great events
in the books and then you get to go
there and stand in those
wonderful halls and say wow the moves of
the great geniuses were being played
exactly here and the fans were there you
can just
feel the excitement in the place
so give you a time machine where would
you go
right now in chess history
paul morphy
one of his paris exhibitions where he
played blindfold chess
and was carried out by the audience yeah
that's what i'm talking uh
that would have been great i'm jumping
i'm jumping to my favorite player in
history
mikhail tal the moment he becomes world
champion beating bod vinik
that would be one of the
50 or so that come to mind but
that would just simply be awesome to be
able to witness
firsthand i'll be boring and say um
reykjavik first fast key fisher
there you go i love iceland
yeah speaking of boring uh i'll quickly
wrap up this topic
in 1992 i went to the island of svettie
stefan where the rematch was being
uh taking place between bobby fischer
and boris basket 5 million dollar
rematch
and bobby stayed in the hotel
in the sophia loren
suite and there was a plaque that said
the
sofia lorenz suite and i turned to an
event i said when this
event is over they're going to call that
the bobby fischer suite
back everyone as let's take a quick look
at the standings as the games are about
to start wisley and jeffrey tight at the
top lots of players with a draw
and round two pairings as we saw just
two decisive games in round one
how many will we see in round two
let's take a look at who's playing who
well we've got a big game always when we
look at hiku nakamura
um he's gonna be playing against alex
landerman who's coming off a loss
will alex be able to survive that one
with a double black
um a rough start sam janklin um against
jeffrey zhang one of the leaders
huge game as well and that's what we're
starting with as
we've got a queen's gambit something
that
people have been binging a lot lately
and here we have it on the board
of course i was referring to the netflix
series but
um looks like uh jeffrey hasn't made his
second move yet guys
we do actually have d take c4 by jeffrey
on the board knight f3 knight f6 queen
a4
check so queen gambit accepted with
queen a4 check
white looks to pick up the pawn in this
fashion
after for example knight b87 i used to
play the queen's gambit accepted a lot
myself and when i had these positions as
black
they often went into a kind of
a catalan i want to say that usually
goes like this
where i get to play bishop b5 some
players went queen c6 but after
rook b8 and bishop b7 i kicked the queen
out
so queen's gambit accepted on the board
all very
well and theoretical did we want to
choose out make makeup picks of
who we think will be 2020
uh us champion i
i'll pay i think murray's kind of
already made his pick unless he
um was just being rhetorical but i
thought he picked nakamura is that right
maurice yes
yep i'm picking naca okay i'll pay
i'll pick well you know i have i'm split
between two picks and i want a diversity
of picks so maybe i'll let yas go back
okay i'm gonna go with wesley so because
when you win a u.s championship i
you know even the u.s championship side
titles that i won
where everything flew went my way
somewhere somehow you got a little lucky
myself included and i just think that
when i looked at wesley sews game
that was very fortunate that he won that
ending so
right now the signs are telling me
wesley so 2020 us champion
great picks no doubt as you guys picked
two elite players and i think var
um picked one of those as well right
voroussian picked either knock or so i
believe
okay but you're going to come up with
something
fabulous i mean it's not that out on a
limb because
it's a young man who's leading the
tournament i'm going to go with jay x
oh i love it love it he's going to win a
u.s championship one of these days right
and he's so young
i've always said if you're not gonna win
the u.s junior championship
make it up by winning the u.s
championship
and and i'll say you know it's kind of
curious how
my co-commentators pick two players who
won in the first round
we're leading the tournament right now
right
sure you're uninfluenced by the data in
any way
purely objective even though you
admitted that you were yes
yeah i'm willing to stick with my guns
and say all right if my guy had lost
maybe i might have
okay but i'm going with
who i came with the horse i rode in on
and it's not such a bad
thoroughbred to pick given his
incredible abilities in rapid
he's been fantastic but that said
he's still got to go up against really
good players and he's not in the lead
right now so we'll see and by the way in
that game ikara versus lindemann
i mean is is it really fair that you
have to have black you know you're going
to get two blacks in a row
i'm going to get two blacks to start the
torment so let's see let me get black
against wesley so
any karo nakamura no no
that's unfair that's unfair i mean i
gotta look at that fide rule book i mean
the number one and number two seeds you
know you get black in the back
to start the tournament no that's not
right but i mean
i'm calling a foul that is interesting i
mean
that's not fair the nightmare is start
the good news is he'll have a lighter
way to go if he can just survive this
game
it should be easier theoretically
speaking from here and
here on out and he'll have an extra
white against the rest of the field so
he just needs to not go
o2 right now yeah you got the on coals
for a couple miles burning coals but
when it's over
it will be really blocking head exactly
exactly but meantime by the way look at
ikaru we we're used to seeing him be
emotional emotive and look at i mean
he's karen pulling all kinds of faces
at the moment what's up i never know
with hikaru
uh what the facial expressions mean
let's
pick up the game in fact so it was a
karo khan the two knights variation
now normally speaking karo khan players
in this exact position
uh the most popular move is to play the
move bishop g4 which is the whole
purpose of playing the car account
uh play a french defense but get your
light square bishop
out from behind the e6 pawn uh
taking on d4 actually works in white's
favors it kind of
avoids a lot of variations
now on the other hand if you're willing
to play knight f6
then your move order as black doesn't uh
make any difference queenie two
okay we all we have to say it but don't
you dare fall for smother checkmate
you and about a thousand other players
have fallen
for that one queen e2 takes takes
what bishop e6 now that is really
confusing because
okay knight d7 knight f6 has been played
a gajillion times
wow b2b3 so
we're really off the beaten track now
with these last
two moves and
okay queen e3 bishop f5
now here i just want to wax and wayne a
little poetically for just a moment
uh there are some really really really
strong players in the world that
just aren't what you would say world
class aren't going to be world champion
um when you're playing against these
really really strong players they get
what we would call their comfort zone
now with this move bishop
f5 basically what alex is saying i want
to get into my comfort zone
i want to play the move e6 i want to
play the move bishop e7 i want to play
the move castles
now hikaru is just one of those players
that intuits what
the opponent's comfort zone might be he
can see
that with this moves bishop e6 and
bishop f5
the second move bishop f5 alex is going
to get into his comfort zone what does
he do
he he plays two moves that
well may or may not be
the best but they get you out of your
comfort zone
knight d4 uh pardon me let me put it
back
knight d4 attacks the bishop while
simultaneously
uh defending the pawn on f2 castles
wasn't the only move
the bishop dropped back and now once
again alex is just thinking please
please
let me get e6 bishop ec 7 i'm perfectly
happy
f4 now in case of e6 f5 and
oops suddenly it's not so comfortable
so alex has to make a move that maybe he
wasn't
prepared to make a moment ago and he
played
after f4 queen a5 and by the way alex
says that bishop g6 was a novelty
uh queen d7 had been played before
and yeah my
we've been studying his openings quite a
lot yes and one of the lines
that he really likes is this line
against the carol um
yeah yeah and um he was showing me and
the
the girls club at us chess he was giving
us a giving them a
lecture and he was showing them this
line actually
and some of the like like with trading
queens like queen d5 instead of bishop
e6 and how strong
the bishop on that long diagonal is when
you get
the b3 and bishop b2 moves in wait wait
wait did you say your brother yeah greg
he really likes this he was he was
giving a lesson on this
opening exactly actually this the two
nights versus the caro
and um i i just uh i remember in that
game
he was showing how black was trying to
get a queen trade on the board and so
to me it's actually kind of scary for
lendermen because
i'm just thinking that white's pieces
are so active
not trading queens it's going to be
really risky
and and the reason why i said did you
say your brother
you know really likes the opening he's
giving all the training to people
are you giving away trade secrets is
greg thinking wait
wait wait wait wait why are you telling
everybody what i'm doing
in this line now for admission
oh the lessons on youtube guys oh okay
okay
he's already spilled he'd already
spilled the beans i see all right
okay okay so hold on hold on
finish your thought there so jen the
on youtube folks who are watching the
show can go
and freely watch and what should they
search for us
chess chess federation's youtube channel
yeah
and there's a there's a series of
classes but mostly by female players but
we're starting to mix it up and get some
um you know tatev's taught there irena's
taught there but
and we're starting to mix it up because
we're having these every week so
obviously um they can learn from some
some grandmasters of all genders um
but what what i was saying was that greg
was talking about
black attempting to trade queens right
and
with this active play with queens on the
board it does seem very enticing to me
and i have to say after that lesson
i had always played the pan of attack
against the carol khan and
i really didn't get that much especially
in like a classical time control so i
it was very appealing to me the idea of
having active play and not having a
really weak pawn on d4
yeah especially isolated fun so
how dangerous did you find um the two
knights variation against the cairo
not at all not at all not at all
no not in the least and the pan off
never scared me although i respected it
a lot
the only variation today
that really causes grief or angst
is the advanced variation and it's
double double edged i mean you just got
to know backward and forward i just
wanted to reinforce
what greg was saying in his class and
that is that
black should be playing for the move
queen d8 d5 jen
yeah well that was just the mainland
offering a trade question offering
yeah offering the trade queens yeah it
seems like linderman has come up with
with a novelty here as version said but
i but it's but to me it seems risky
that's all because the harmony and the
development of white's pieces just
seemed superior
now after queen a5 though um as
so the novelty is bishop g6 and queen d7
was previously played
and then after f4 sorry jen please queen
a5 and now
um which way so you're thinking just
bishop c4 and castle's king side is
going to happen in the position that's
what happened well
bishop c4 has happened
a long time we should note to get to
queen a5
linderman spent something like 17
seconds
plus his obviously five second
increments he was at 24
and 43 or 46 even i mean he hadn't used
no time to play queen e5 he just went
and got to this position and then when
bishop c4 landed on the board
he tanked and spent quite some time
before finally making this advanced e6
so must be that he's out of his prep now
or trying to remember his prep
at the moment because clearly ee6 is
signaling
with red flags to black to white
hey sack on e6 if you want to
go right ahead you want to try to take a
piece and see if there's damage
you got two different ways to take and
then after that you'll have another two
different ways to capture
i don't believe it i think he's gonna
fail
that must have been something he sat on
for a while and there's no question that
nakamura
who paused before playing bishop c4 is
wondering about taking on these six
i mean he you know i want to do it
five looks scary too oh you just had
because you don't have e5
i just take on g6 right right
here here i'm thinking of the move
castles
so i'm getting my king out of dodge i'm
preparing the move you want to play gen
which is f5
now i'm assuming bishop e7 because i
don't think black wants to put his king
there and this is what you're talking
about memories like
is this peace sacrifice this knight is a
monster
your king isn't going left it's not
going right
now that your bishop is on e7 your pawn
on g7 is hanging i've got two pawns
what kind of nasty kind of threat of f5
and knight g7
is it worth a piece what happening is
bishop c5 exactly another thing is
identification bishop c5
bishop c5 i didn't think you could do it
because of
this okay and then hold the holder
holder
uh time for castles i'm just just
thinking about it
yeah good idea it might be one of those
where you give
give the pawn up but i got a pin i got
rook e8
and d8 coming knight to g4 coming bishop
c2
pawn on c2 is actually hanging out as
well if you want to be ridiculous about
it
but if i take it after queen takes e6
king
f8 what's your what's your money what's
my big
my my my big move because the pumpkin b4
is pinned still because of this f4
advance right
so exactly you can't just like retreat
your queen and thread in 96.
exactly very very queen is leading as
well
f5 i guess you could try a five here
if i bishop f7 yeah that seems like a
problem i'd be happy to see that
yeah that's not the way i wanted to to
continue no i must admit no that's not
it's not going it doesn't feel like the
it's getting the job done castles bishop
c5
f5 bishop takes right
no but f5 can i take with
no i can't because now i'll take yeah i
wanted to
i want to try to trick you with bishop
takes d4 but rook a5 and i'm the one
who's trick
so that doesn't work so
f5 bishop takes on d4 looks forced
but wait a minute isn't your
there there isn't some overworked queen
here
uh if there's no overwork queen by the
way something even like bishop f6 one
day is not
going to be very nice uh let's see
let's have a look see b4
take it i think you have to take it
there's not much of a choice right
here i'm just looking at rook f5 and
rook f6
as well as rook five and bishop f uh
f6 um you're currently down two pawns
so you gotta you got stuff to prove
as you're sacrificing exactly exactly i
am sacrificing two
nasty pawns um with the pawn on d3
i'm hoping that you're not going to
castle and allow bishop c5
uh i'm kind of hoping that you will
castle long and then i've opened up the
beef up
um i hesitate to say
i would only want to go into that
sacrifice with some pretty decent
prep yeah exactly because you're tossing
stuff to the window
it might be correct but you're like
here's one here's two
here's a rhythm you take it with you oh
i have another idea how's this for
cutesy
maybe it's too cute but it isn't i've
been playing for the e file control so
that i can play rook f5
this is a bizarre peculiar like
what uh you can't play bishop g6
because of takes and you can't defend
the g7 pawn
oops so castle i'm castling queenside so
fast hassling you you you won't even see
my pieces move
i'm out okay i
won back upon though you did you did but
you're d-pawn and bishop's hanging
your queen is ready to come where eve
i don't know because i do have knight h5
here just to be disruptive
to force you to play i'd have to go even
like weenie five move
and now either i trade queens like a
wimp
or or i take on d2
and and hold my breath
maybe he's not bothered
is that like in the chess informant code
you know like
be a wimp you know like okay an emoji
uh we'll leave this game alone why only
to say
it is fun it is last note last note
hikaru is down to 12 34. we know he's
fast
but there's some uncertainty here as
he's considering this position
and all the wild ramifications that
we've looked at and more
no doubt all kinds of creative ideas to
try to figure out
how he should approach this concrete
position and he's going to make some
aggressive f5 move or he's going to
castle
we know that one of those is we suspect
one of those is coming
but he also has the sac on e6 so a
plethora of choices guys
hikaru shaking his head not sure what to
do
as soon as i said it f5 is on the board
sometimes
it's nice to have a crystal clear
singular path you just know really this
is your
this is your path of glory when you've
got you know five six
eight really attractive options you can
just burn a lot of clock
and your wheels keep spinning he's he
sacrificed the pawn is he ready to play
castles and uh go into those crazy
uh sacrifices we'll leave it be for a
second let's just
take a quick look around the horn
alejandro ramirez versus wesley so
i'll tell everybody once again that
wesley so
has been my pick so i want to see how
wesley is doing
it's one of those another one of those
weird
zveznikov uh positions right with this
pawn
on d5 the kingside minority versus the
queen site
now keep in mind alejandro was fabi's
second along with lanier dominguez and
christian
gorilla so
you would think that alejandro would
have
a lot of prep in these positions yes
yes uh just just to
alert you we did look at one position
that just
flows naturally that is the icaru
position falls naturally into the awanda
liang great robson
position we have the same opening line
right in front of us in that game as
well
if we can just back up a few moves to
see the queen e2 move get played
in this opening and look at how white
look you just look at
you're gonna have to go slowly to
explain this to the folks because
after this boom first of all in 95 f7 is
under threat you see 95 and f7 that's a
mate
don't touch the queen or you get mated
first step
all right we got that down now keep it
going
slowly but surely look at what happens
after 95 e6
queen back and the move wow played here
but beef bubble what b5
b5 we can hear c6 pawn with tempo
bishop d3 first of all we have to wonder
about knight c6 could we just understand
why
knight c6 was not playable i suspect
it has something to do with the fact
that this pawn on g2
um gets
uh targeted somehow like something well
here
there should be seven walks into a
discovery so maybe it's bishop
d7 the knight on c6 doesn't have a good
reach well it's got it
you can't retreat to e5 it goes to d4
it's captured that might be it it's just
that's that
that's that yeah so okay
although there no no there wasn't a
queen it was a queen c4 in that position
but then rook c8 so let's
close out that line okay e5 knight c6
queen
and you said there's a queen c4 you got
to defend the knight
okay but now rook c8 answers and cleans
it and
ends the variation so not not playable i
see no tricks here
to follow up so so b5 and white said
i'll just back up
and queen c7 and white said well
uh excuse me wow
a4 a4 right tickling on that side and
after bishop d6 he took it
now they made a bishop yeah
and you want to recapture with the pawn
if you could play
a4 takes b5 and cement the knight on c6
you're golden
so that was why we saw ray play b5
before now
he sacrificed the pawn for some
initiative
how good is it knight d4 well we're
about to find out the knight
eyeballing two potential attacking
squares b5
and f5 a6
by the way a big long think went into
the move a7 a6
we're at a nine minute thing look at
look at the time differential in the
game guys knight f5
lands on the board hitting the bishop
hitting the pawn on g7
got it give me another pawn king had to
move
knight dropped back to h5 he's stolen
two pawns in the process
and then after queen takes he said you
can have the jeep on if you like because
i'll play rook g1
your king's exposed and ray said no i'm
not feeling that let's go for
this line although his h-pawn is hanging
a queen eight six check to come
white is behind in terms of development
for real i mean wright wants to play
bishop leave d3 play somehow push my
d-pawn
get my bishop in the game or b3 get my
bishop in the game castle
i'm not even sure he wants to cast on
that side it does look like
compensation here uh without any
question for the
for the material is it
i mean is this preparation
or inspiration at the board look at the
play black has
i think it's a combination of both
because you study a lot you study a lot
and you really get to the point where
you
feeling the tactics and the strategies
of certain openings
certain systems and then you just get
this kind of feeling like
yeah that's active that's good so
the more you study the more you more
knowledge you
acquire about a certain system uh
you get at the board then you suddenly
say oh this is inspiring because
this matches up with that uh something
i've studied and i feel like even though
i'm two pawns down i've got a lot of
activity you mentioned
uh maurice that i want to move this deep
on want to move my bishop want to
develop
so let's just look at the most forcing
let's say i capture a pawn
and again we just like look at the most
forcing
you capture upon i get to do what i want
which is to
open up my um bishop
so i can play it now you go back
help me if uh doing something wrong with
a tempo
i have wanted to play bishop h6 but now
that it doesn't come with a tempo
i think i have to respect the threat to
my rook
and here uh
this should be good for white right so
uh help me out what do i do i don't know
that
i just don't know i mean you don't have
to take you don't have to retreat your
rook
my rook's in the position i'd love i'd
love to do something more
dynamic okay that fair enough because
what i did when i retreated my rook was
not
good for black okay i'm i'm feeling
bishop h6
check and castles as
my plan as one like
i really want to get my queen in there
and the queen on c7
feels like he wants to get somewhere
where would it go though
e2 f1 e4 i don't see anywhere bishop
takes on h7
has been played and rook g2 so we are in
the position right now
d4 you is your next move you want to
play
bishop 86 this is actually one of those
really funny positions too because d4 is
automatic
but then you start to think and somehow
you start to think to yourself
gee it would be maybe fun to have my
bishop so then you start thinking well
maybe d3
here the difference is there's a queen
c2 that i have to
calculate i would say d4 is an automatic
if i was playing in a classical chess
tournament i'd start to think of
alternatives like d3 now
you're mentioning the queen on c7 it
would like to get in and i'm thinking
your gateway is the f4 square
i would want to stop bishop h6 if i was
in black shoes
so maybe bishop f4
take take and put your queen on f4
tickle f2
that would be nice i would take that i
would take that the only problem is a
queen c5 potential that's disruptive
but it's king g7 not gonna yeah it's
helping
definitely helping black black
if that happens king jesus christ all
the black pieces are organized so that's
works that
that's not a problem okay but then it
begs the question what about bishop e3
oh opening up the rank i know i know
uh but i'm trying to keep the queen
out of f49 don't forget your roof is
hanging your rook is hanging
this guy here the rook in the corner so
this allows x-ray
rook c2 trickery
here wait a minute now i now i'm the one
who's about to be disruptive
queen h6 might ask you where your king
is
heading this rook could e-8
this rook could or could not my bishop
is guarding the rook so
what if you play check i have king d7
and you don't have another check so i'm
not as
scared here i might play rook b2 here
for example with the
queen c3 check and you have you have a
check but it's not
it's not killing my feelings yeah and
bishop before is on the board
i mean black is black is ringing
on white right now he is down two pawns
but his development is extraordinary
right what an incredible position what
nice because
wow
and knock on words getting crazier too
and well let's go back to hikaru's game
because
when we left it it was already he played
the move
f5 when we left it and he had tanked
10 minutes or longer had ikaru to get
here and castles came immediately uh
those pawn grubbers amongst us might
have considered bishop c5 and bishop g6
lenderman said let me just get out of
dodge i'm out of here
goodbye goodbye and icarus said a pawn's
a pawn
and guess what uh
i've got a threat lenderman
rook d2 that's the movie
okay that that could leave you
discombubilated where did rook d2 come
out of well there's a bishop
if bishop c3 there would have been a
bishop c5
c5 so get the king out of there before
bishop c5 happens
oh okay i got it i got it okay and by
the way there
i mean okay i i'm just
i'm just playing catch up with the
players but
there was rook f5 as well right
with the idea that if you take my rook
i wanted to take your queen if i take
your queen
no bishop c5 anymore
hmm
no but i do have here i do have queen v6
here
you only got your pawn back so what if i
just offer a trade of queens queen b6
queen boy6 yes okay i only want to put
oh geez you only when you're pawn back
so
party basically you know do your worst
you could
you could trade queens and win a pawn on
f6 i don't think you want to do that
obviously position etcetera so okay
that fully explains king h1 absolutely
on the button
knight g4 doesn't anybody believe in
development anymore
you're supposed to get your pieces out
before you attack
not according to alex letterman you
attack whenever you get an opportunity
mcqueen sixth check king over and now
queenie eight doesn't do anything
because the king can go to
the rook and go back to d8 actually and
boot you out of there so
now you need a move and there's some
issues yourself potential
who knows over over on the h2 square in
a knight f2 check so he said
resolve the position of your knight
mister h3
usually when you see a move like this
you want to play h5
and just say i'm going to just be
obstinate
i'm telling you it's that you got to be
careful
it's a ghost of our uh us champion frank
marshall
h2h3 h7h5 was a retort favorite
rook d6 instead whoa
what okay
this game is crazy the idea here
is like a moment ago h5
look at nakamura sorry sorry yes look at
nakamura
he is shaking his head and visibly
destroyed
all of a sudden look look at his i mean
look at these faces he's looking like
is this for real like what's going on in
this position
how did this happen
nice wow what is is he losing or
something like what is he
doing i don't know but that's got to be
a gif
file there i mean you know like my head
shaking uh
the the funny part of this exact moment
is when you play the move h5 the whole
idea is to open up the h file
obviously for a rook now when you see
the move rook
d6 in this position it's funny too it
just basically means
don't think about touching that knight
obviously the queen is
attacked as well but that was a very
funny move and a very strange reaction
reaction and icarus so let me out of
here i don't know what's going on no
anymore
i'll trade queens how how good or bad is
this
the knight comes back the rook is about
to come back
it has looks nice for lenderman because
bishop e5 is a threat um and your knight
on h6 is terrible so i guess you're
going to take it
but now i'm running bishop b5 and your
g7 pawn is in capture
so you're going to win them unless you
play rook g6
you don't i wasn't on for dear life yeah
i'm not gonna
in fact thinking about my next two moves
is black
yeah i'm thinking in terms of moving my
rook and then moving my bishop so maybe
i should do it
this way jen yeah i wanted that d file i
was hoping you're going to give me that
d
file because i want to really do you
want so badly
i can also play rook f1 to get you to
move your bishop away and then take on
seven with a rock yeah and then you're
thinking
about when yeah don't don't oh yeah i
forget you've got a
you've got a king yourself i mean it's
not
it's not gonna be just your king is
going to
start walking a little bit right
if we got two rooks on the seventh a
potential extra point coming
the issue is where does this walk lead
no no totally covered no no it looks
it looks good uh linderman played this
really quickly to get
to get here i mean this is not
here is good for white this is looking
really good for white i don't see why
this should be
any worries whatsoever seriously uh
now if i no i can't by the way bishop e5
is absolutely a threat if i drop back
with my rook to d2
and you grab the open file
i could potentially hang on for dear
life like this
but this is definitely seizing the
defensive here
and i'm not a big fan rook d2 by
lenderman on the
board but it looks like they're going to
go into that line that
uh jen how did you do it you used double
ropes
i started with rooks trying to just nice
gotta play gotta move the bishop gotta
move the bishop now
i i chose c5 that didn't work out so
well last time
maybe d6 is better maybe d6 is a better
choice
but there's a king c8 against that it
turns out king c8
okay so but i kind of want your king
i don't know where i want your king okay
so help me out here guys i'm playing
rook f1 bishop d6
let's just leave it here it's a very
significant advantage hikaru
i'd be really surprised if lenderman
hangs on and what a rotten way
to start the u.s championship for alex
linderman i mean
two blacks in a row against two of the
highest-rated guys in the tournament
let's just check in the rape game ray's
done
ray is done they won the game wow
okay when we left it we left it these
parts
and he did not a wonder did not play
bishop
e3 he played queen h4
and guess what that king
is we're not really seeing the game
sorry one second
okay so let's get the game in somewhere
for the fans to see
oh here we are okay sorry i'll go back
to exactly
we left it a wonder did not play the
move bishop e3 he played queen h4
but this left his bishop high and dry
simply stranded on h7
the idea is to play king g7 and where
are you going with your king
uh well a wonder said oh no the
immediate threat
wasn't the immediate threat rook g7
right there oh no you have
yeah rook g7 and hit your rook hit your
rook on attack
on uh on h1 and if queen f16 we can just
play queen f7
and you got zero yeah you're winning
material no question about it rook g7
very
powerful threat king d2 i'm not liking
it
now at this point oh i i can
i see very very very nasty things
happening here for
london
we're repeating in the game between
shanklin and jeffrey zhang so that means
that jeffrey's now on one and a half
that means the only other player who can
get that perfect score would be wesley
so
as he started off with a win and he's
right now battling against ramirez
um ramirez
yeah i was about to say this looks like
a fantastic game by ray
roberts happy chess
game that's just ridiculously good yes
ridiculously good
alejandra alejandra versus ramirez
versus wesley
um jen you were saying well
if ray if wesley doesn't win this it
means that there will be a big
tie at the end of the round with one and
a half points right wesley's not winning
this
yeah i don't think so i open color i
mean
you know it's this is a beautiful i mean
really pat yourself on the back
a beautiful positional pawn sacrifice
and you get your king on e5 but then you
kind of just
stop i mean it just kind of fizzles
you're here
and again you pat yourself on the back
but
you're not playing g4 this guy is real
and you're not winning the pawn so uh
when he destly decided to do it another
way he went
g4 and alejandro had a a stunned
reaction by the way to that move
he looked at it because he still has
that look on his face like what is he
thought
that wasn't playable because i'm sure
alejandro was thinking
well i can take it or i can
even play rook h1 and rook to
h5 h6 but what is wesley's idea i
suppose it has to be
it's e4 and f4 this
yes and i'm not sure i'm not sure it's
winning or
close but but i like i like black sorry
i do like the pawn sacrifice in that
case i
don't think i would take this you know i
love my pawns
but i think it's time to play rook h
take once on g4 but then follow it up
with rook h1 for white
and i think alejandro will will make a
piece
but i think the game that's going to
entertain us the most is ryan
is serious he took by the way he's
allowed this variation
he did take okay so he's really pressing
his luck here okay what could be his
idea okay he's probably
what does he think there's a king e5 and
bishop
d4 i was looking at this line myself
rook king up and now if you play bishop
f5 bishop d4
surprisingly just stopping that thread
hitting your b-pawn
and yeah black is what you got beauty
no black is beautifully coordinated if
he could get
rook b5 and rook d5 on the board uh
so what is alejandro sorry jen you were
going to take it somewhere
where would you we can stay with it so
it looks like um so actually has found a
way to get a lot of pressure
true he is pausing at this point but i i
would think that you came here
after what looks like a pawn sack yeah
you'd be ready to play f4
right making sure that there's no way as
alejandro has boldly jumped
forward into this line isn't there
another line to play maybe rook
and the f4 is on the board rook h1 now
but that king is just slithering into
the d4 square
and what are you doing progress on every
move what a fascinating endgame
yeah it is truly and by the way it looks
like alejandro just took a swig of
something i think it must have been like
a
a ginger ale or something yeah right
what is the trolley what are the drinks
of
uh of champion grand masters i always
like
water and orange juice at my
my games what were your favorite drinks
coffee and water
coffee and water you maurice water
teas just wanted no teas i thought you
were t you like tease uh
i do but not in the games i would drink
water
uh boris they didn't just stay hydrated
he's a big team man in fact
he would bring these big thermoses you
know like these
industrial
size thermoses and he'd have his tea all
nicely at the board
um okay f4 on the board i i agree with
you maurice uh
this is slithering the heck is the move
i'm seeing i'm seeing easy moves for
black
bishop is coming to e3 king is coming to
uh
to um e5 so you can capture this pawn on
f5 and alejandro he took this bond and
allowed these pawns to advance
so he must have an idea i'm wondering
about a line using my g-pawn
as a distraction but i haven't the king
can come over
as well what if i play rook a4 king e5
g5
rook a4 gift me the pawn king e5
g5 so this is your
but let's say i take it
i'm going to play rook a6 i'm thinking
you can't do everything you want
i can't do everything i want why not i
want to do everything i want
okay and i took it
now i want to take this now you know no
i i
see what you want to do just for the
audience uh
remember uh pau banco
pounded it into my head rooks belong
behind past pawns
and here we see why uh you're not going
to allow that i know maurice you
had something no no no now i want to
back
the bishop up and guard this pawn the
pawn
king of one you look like you have an f3
that might just yeah
but i was i was going to invite you to
to that experience and it's not good now
here
the whole thing is the king the white
king
is the one who is um
tactically vulnerable if you agreed i
can't i can't keep you out
i can't keep you out this pawn is not a
true deflecting pawn
look i preferred what you said
before before maybe rook h1 to
i don't know i think you have to play it
yeah
but the king again is going to slither
forward but at least you keep your g
pawn and f3 is very hard to get
right in this position everybody i can
imagine
this is this is much more double edged
and by the way you don't just want
wesley
to show you how he's going to win you
want wesley to
have some doubts you want to you know so
something like hey you got to be careful
too
okay i called it a root beer
every every kind of like brown thing it
looks like maybe it's like a soda
root beer am i getting it wrong tom
somebody else get it right
every dutch dutchman would call that a
heineken but i don't think
it is sparkling water
okay i know carrier pair your water okay
you know he obviously is a fun-loving
guy very popular in the chess world but
he's
like ultra serious when it comes to
training and playing absolutely at the
board no question
no way yeah no he respects the game a
lot
uh let's leave this game here i just
want to talk by the way the only
there's only one flaw that sorry we need
to inspect this
alejandro is down to 219 and wesley at
10 minutes
and wow there is a big point to moving
your rook off the h file
the a file is that black could take the
a5
rook h1 can be met by rook a8
and i don't like that position at all
like you can go checking all you like
the black king is ending up on d4 i
don't know how to defend this position
if i'm blind i feel like if i'm white i
feel like i'm lost
and he and he has played g5 in
what looks like frantic desperation
about how to defend here
because he saw all these tricks that
black was developing
what a remarkable conception g4 was
g4 that looked impossible for him to
break the pawn structure
wall with g4 capture twice then play
e4 and f4 and have these two nasty
looking pawns as black
that was very instructive absolutely
um you know reaching into his bag
of tricks or with his back to the wall
however you want to put it i really like
this move
g5 check a lot like that might be
in my opinion the only saving move
because
if you just allow black's king to waltz
in and whether this rook activates
itself on the age file
or maybe on the a file as you were
mentioning
uh maurice king e5 it looks really
really bad so why not use your pawn as a
decoy
at distractions yes he didn't he didn't
bite he said
you can push all you want king e5 is in
the position
and he is not afraid he's got the rook
g8 idea is back in business
okay wait a minute wait a minute this is
exactly the type of thing i was talking
about a second ago
is i mean wesley is having the fun
wesley is
wesley's pushing the action no question
about it but as
white you also want wesley to respect
what's going on
uh the move g5 check you know that's
a pawn that's the extra pawn that's
white's pocket king e5
bishop e6 and i would yeah i was about
to say now with the bishop on e6
uh aren't i making the g pawn
reel okay rook h8 i get it i get it i
really do
you want to go at rook h2 now
i want to start with f3 g6 on the board
g6 played first on the board
okay by the way down to 46
seconds 46 years and cry he's in a
crisis and
g8 rook a6 played
a fan of instantly of g6 no no no i
i was later we'll go down that rabbit
hole
of uh bishop e6 but at the moment
rook a6 bishop c5 and by the way this is
what wesley does
he is really good at keeping the
pressure
up he he makes
for what he thinks is a forced move the
bishop is attacked
he doesn't think it over as white you
want
your opponent to think about bishop d4
bishop e3
bishop g1 no he just says
look uh i'm going to be very practical
the bishop is good on c5
i play it quickly your clock your time
is ticking and we have moves we have we
have
really bad moves for alejandro fans as
rook takes and he's we're about to see
that move you mentioned yes
that just stopped me in my tracks rook
g3 rook b3
i gotta say black is totally winning
this position
exactly meanwhile somebody who's not
winning anymore guys
as a surprise it looks like somehow
lenderman has defended as it's
too two rooks and two pawns each
and um i just don't well when we left it
we left it here we everybody loved your
move
uh jen rook f1 bishop g7 that's
isn't that called cashing your chips too
early
as now lenderman says okay i don't see
why i can't maintain material parity
oh and yeah no
i mean now that he's got nothing in this
position
well maybe yeah maybe rick f1 didn't
work i don't know
well maybe it looked better for white
wow but it's surprising
there was that bishop d6 variation right
yeah
yeah and we hadn't completely figured
that out but it just looked like white
had so many ideas it seemed hard to
believe that
winning somehow yeah exactly i would
have played rook f1
and followed your instinct there jen
because you want the bishop to move i
mean
this move bishop g7 you're helping black
develop his bishop and
it's sort of like you're saying to black
no you never transgressed
uh your your failure to ever make a
development
move was perfectly logical it's like
what
it was that's a good idea like if you
didn't want to go work at one rookie one
in that line would have fronted me
on yeah exactly one way or the other
trying to get
keep the rooks on the board and the
bishops rather the bishops on the board
trading off the bishops is just you know
a well-known principle and obviously
hikaru knows
better better than almost anyone that
rook end games
are very drawlish so keeping like the
bishops on makes it a little bit juicier
right
even if eventually they get traded off i
wasn't paying too much attention to the
clocks maybe it was a factor
it doesn't seem like it would have been
at that moment but okay
defense for wesley after rook f1 and
just figured you know if there's a
defense against that maybe i just have
to go for this
um which is still i'm sure he was the
one on top but at this point
guys guys we got to get back to the
games that are winning though decisive
positions and the game
with alejandro and wesley wesley has
been mired
in thought yes this position that you
said
that we i agreed with you rook g3 and
cash in your chips you put your behind
and and then you're going to play rook
b2
he he's been spending quite okay and he
played it and there it's on the board
alejandro played b7 and bishop to c8
quickly
and at least the rook cannot leave
okay uh the b file because yeah uh
of a queen but i got a feeling it's all
about the dark at the
the king and it is like not really i
mean
i'm not happy here we're at tempo to
we're a tempo problem here right like
we play king d1 and we're eight we're
just yeah we're just
losing by a tempo huh yeah it's like one
of those things that you
get here and it's like please let it be
my move
now i've gotta drop back and there goes
mine look at that
e3 by wesley with the threat of
king c1 trying to disrupt this this rook
okay he's trying to fight but bishop d4
is gonna end
and that um
um i'm i'm also thinking e2
king takes queen queen
is there a mate i suspect it's winning
i suspect there is i suspect there is a
winning continuation giving away the
rook
i'm sure because he's got the time
wesley's considering it let's just have
a quick look-see
if this uh if there is a checkmate for
wesley or not here like
where could the king go you know how i
would like
you know it's like one of those things
where you would like
uh the checkmate how can i do it
something like this would be pretty
but actually there's a win that was
strong and it looks like everything else
wins the queen
the new queen on v8 looks like he goes
lost
like if you get it you walk into that
very famous skier uh ideas right
so i suspect it is winning i
think wesley could could probably win it
more pedantically i want to say with the
move
but your line is fantastic if that works
oh no your queen d3 check could be met
by
it could be met by uh one unfortunately
he didn't go down the right fortunately
he didn't go down because king c1 yes
and your bishop d4 quincy line king c1
was the reputation
i think oh sorry it would have been
e2 king takes yes uh
quickly because they're they're playing
yeah just play your line and i'm going
to defend
and after queen c3 king to d1 and
d3 why can't i play king c1 gotcha
and ask you how are you going to
construct this mating concept
exactly which is why we didn't see this
he did play
the move bishop d4 did wesley back here
after the move e3
king c1 bishop d4 i yeah this is
easier simpler and
ali hunter alejandro is trying to fight
somehow we don't believe it no this
i mean this pawn this power this passer
is just so strong
also the fact that the king could easily
enter the position as well bishop to c5
king to d4
convinces me that the position is just
bad uh
lastly the rook is going to come to f2 i
think
i mean back
by the way uh just getting news that's
is suddenly up a very important pawn
against lumiere dominguez
whoa three tournament favorites look at
that a pawn go
that's a nasty nasty a-pawn and
oh boy this should be winning
for a sam savion uh with this
oh gorgeous rook too the rook will be
just like brilliantly posted on d3
rook takes f5 everything going
sam's way i don't know what lanier did
hadn't paid too much attention to that
because it looked more
like sedate than some of our other games
yeah exactly hey i mean
sam savion did not have a good start in
the u.s junior championship but you know
we all said it
that having that practice in that
tournament it's so important really
helping for the big dance
exactly could you could you stay on this
game
while he thinks because it's so dramatic
and pull up on your board the other game
with alejandro and wesley because we
know alejandra is a tremendous
blitz player wesley is also a fantastic
player of course
so let's take a look because alejandro
has been fighting
in this position i mean he's battling
he's not just dropping in his game
and that light square blockade i
understand this is bad but
it it's wesley hasn't played sort of the
precise or whatever i don't know
what moves he could have played but this
does not look easy with this blockading
piece right now
yeah we can keep that as the main game
as it does seem like the
the result is more in doubt like i feel
like sam sami on
lumiere is less likely to save the game
than alejandra wait but alejandro just
does something really good bishop
he was fighting he was fighting and he
put his king in a mating net
now he's and get out of there
this is this is going to be bad rookie
one check him again
on f1 and the king's gonna have to leave
yep like king has to go to g4
but then comes rook f10 and the whole
blockade has been broken and
there you go yeah it's the death wow he
was fighting
he took he took his rook off the back
row
and dropped the game in this
in this position and now rook f2 is just
decisive
and he can feel it he's disgusted and
wesley's going to 2-0
he's there alejandro shaking his head
and if you just go back a couple of
moves
i mean wesley has been very fortunate
two games i mean he's playing the games
of course
if you just go back to the moment he
played his rook off the back rank
when the king was on d4 so right about
here
he checked the king and now he could
check the king somewhere
tell him but he left the
ring yeah i i understand what you're
saying you could go
check king f1 bishop f1
bishop e2 keep your bishop on the keep
the dark squares as
light squares pardon me apologies that's
right but rook c2
and hello checkmate in one
and there goes the king and rook f2
wow on such things you know
uh the game turns just like that and it
was uh a win for wesley
okay quickly by wesley by the way two
positions his opponents could have held
end games but they made mistakes in time
pressure
let's jump quickly to the game of hikaru
now
i like to support what you guys were
talking about in the first game that
bishop
ending uh there are certain end games
you should know
not just cold but in your marrow
so to speak and so these positions where
you know the pawn is on g5
versus g4 on g5 instant win
no question about it you win end of
story
g4 no draw
so again uh you know when you come into
these u.s championships and you're down
on the clock
there are certain end games you know in
your marrow and this is one of them
well we'll see as alex is ticking down
and he's not sure what his next move
should be in this position oh what do
you know tragic yes he
if he were to lose another drawn end
game
although i think this one he's probably
looked at
more time much more much much
much much more bishop endings aren't
that common whereas rook endings you
absolutely absolutely have to know
here uh whenever you get the chance the
rule of thumb is to bring your
king in front of the past pawn so king
f6
uh would be my instantly
then i would avoid any king upon end
game
unless i knew it would and okay quickly
check
quickly oh that came upon him that was
the tricky move
he defended the jeep on so he set up a
trap
and by the way sam is about to force
resignation
as it looks like he's actually won
another pawn
and he's winning all the pawns yeah i
can't see anything against yeah
that's got three down you've got it
resigned you don't have to but
he has no time so he's just not
resigning out of inertia right
right that happens so check this check
and h2 or check and g3
big win for sam big win for sam
is still trying to circle yeah
now king f6 now king f6
by uh alex linderman that's an automatic
and he's done it
and now he's got his draw now he's got
an easy draw just move your rook
and make your check and go back and
you've got a philadelphia ghost
appearance yeah
it says as we know i got this we've
known this from the 1700s
smiling now this this one this one's so
in his marrow as you say yes exactly
and he's smiling in relief that he was
able to save this one
it was something like that i think it
was from a dostoyevsky novel where
you know there's cold you get cold in
the wintertime but there's also a
moscow cold a moscow cold
gets into your marrow and
it was like okay i understand what the
writer is saying here
it's really really frozen you get this
rook and pawn end game there are certain
rook component games building bridges
and stuff that you really just have to
know
bravo for alex on a big save
starting oh and two with two blacks in a
row that's
that's bad that would happen half is not
a bad result
half a point against ikaru and wesley
with black is not a bad result he can
feel good about himself
because now he gets more whites five
whites out of his remaining nine games
and he'll be playing against players who
are not as tough as the two top players
in the event i think people would say
lanier is
i mean clearly higher rated than ikaru
in classical
but we're talking rapid chess and we
just saw lanier lose
he's not as we've seen him he's not
he needs a little time on the clock
let's put it that way he's not as frisky
with the with the rapid time control
as he is solid yeah classical i think he
likes the rapid and blitz a little bit
more in real life
that's his rhythm you know like banging
the actual clock it doesn't seem like
it's translating digitally as well as it
does for other players
but what what is he carving white might
as
i don't know the black ones three games
this round guys
ray robson's victory um sam sevillan
and wesley so all with the black pieces
not bad at black ground we're at 130
moves
and still going strong right and he's
[ __ ] nice
now he's played g6 and we could go to
180.
plus i don't think so because the
problem is
the moment the rook leaves the fifth
rank there's a rook check
so you're saying he's going to run out
of repeats he can't make
along along the rank exactly
uh by the way he's going for some kind
of record though i mean he's uh
he's finally played i thought he was
going for 150 but he only made it to
144.
140. disappointing
darius and elshon by the way it looks
like another one of those
really well-prepared games uh you know
you look at the game and you say
man these guys are playing really good
again this is rapid chess
no mistakes in that hard-fought
well-played draw
kudos to el shawn he came in unseated
player
exactly and he has played wonderfully so
far
with the two great draws against higher
rated opponents showing his stuff
showing his skill
and uh here are our standings after two
rounds i believe
we've got our standings wesley so at the
top of the table with a perfect
2-0 we have jeffrey zhang ray robson and
sam
sevi on a very young trio up there tied
for second through fourth
while um a lot of legends there in the
thick of it
caro nakamura defending champ still only
at 50
but so much tournament left to go so
none of this
means that much yet but it does seem
like the players are in very good form
as we take a quick break before we bring
you the last round of the day
but then suddenly f2 f4 i think
uh chandra this is
a real suicide move that just makes
the task all that much easier for
fabiana cariwana because after he
captures the spawn on f4
that knight on h1
is in real trouble and maybe white's
king as well
the e5 check is only helpful for the
second player
moves the king up to f5 so e5 takes f4
has been played
and did we see and no pardon me i think
we
we first saw the move rook d1 check much
more accurate
so shame on me this is a far more
accurate move
king had to go to h2 and now i believe
the pawn has captured on
f4 and that's really putting the
finishing touches
on a splendid game
by the number two player in the world
and about to be the new us champion
as that night on h1 as well and truly
pathetic
what what a great result in terms of um
fairness
right sometimes sometimes in chess it
seems like there is no justice but here
there was justice and that
the two players who played the best chat
seem to be wrapping up the championships
deservedly really really really
deservedly and uh
well again maybe a little bit premature
but fabiano
played a tremendous tournament coming
back
as gary was saying when he was on air
that moscow tournament could take the
sale out of
anybody and normally speaking months to
recover
look what he's done in this event so far
uh
fantastic and you saw his attitude it
was a little different i think
than nakamura's and that he was super
relaxed he's enjoying that kind of
strategy to just like you know turn it
off and not put too much pressure on
himself because he could
easily be exhausted exactly he went to
the conventional booth he's been out to
dinner
exactly you know girlfriend it's like
it's
he's having fun without him and it
worked out for him but guys
you know you're you're describing it
like he just he just
walked in the park uh in forest park
here all day long
nine rounds fantastic chess no hiccups
whatsoever
the game against definitely felt the
pressure in that game and if god had
found
bishop e6 instead of bishop takes knight
he would have had problems in that
position as nakamura said
i don't see how he saves himself and
then today
he missed rook d1 rook d1 in the game
and he could have been under pressure
yet again so
yes he had a smooth performance in the
first nine rounds but the last two he
did feel the pressure
manage of course to be who he is and
save the games
against komski got the draw this one
he's going to win but
even even so you know you have to
respect the fact that it's not easy to
win a u.s championship
by just sailing all the way through and
we saw
even him with his illustrious play did
have some difficulties in the last two
rounds
it was kicking himself how you brought
up that just that
one one move that window of opportunity
right here on my board
where the
maurice just mentioned rook on a1 to d1
was missed because thanks to this
fantastic
uh tactical shot after the the move
queen c6
the queen has to keep protection of the
bishop
um the rook discovers an attack against
this rook which is nicely protected by
this one
which suddenly oop excuse me
after the move bishop takes f7 check
oh my oh my you cannot recapture with
the rook
because you need to protect this rook
and if you
capture with the king then
queen c4 check and the tables have been
completely turned
in white's favor so uh
there has been two hiccups in other
words
uh flawless uh performance
not a walk through the park not the most
typical tactic but
i i wonder you know i was wondering if
fabiano saw it after he played his move
because i had this
you know he played bishop c3 so quickly
after btxc3 i was wondering if it was
like
almost like a relief capture like thank
god he didn't say it
you know like let me just get that
situation out of there
what do you think do you think cause a
lot of times people do i mean especially
lower rate of players they um they make
a blunder
and they see it as soon as their hand
gets off the piece and that's such a
frustrating feeling
you're right i will we're about and here
we go ask him
yes the new
us champion congrats to fabiano
hello everyone welcome back to the 2020
u.s chess championship
where we have a soul leader wesley so
lots of
crowded action at the top though
including jeffrey ray and sam
all with one and a half points let's see
how the parents shake out for round
three because there are some goofy ones
including this matchup between
sam sevion who's off to a great start
playing white against chrono nakamura
who has yet to score a win
this is a big game um as is the game
between ray robson
also to a great start against sam who's
on two draws and
are another front-runner jeffrey john
playing in his fairies
and wesley against wander leon who lost
his first two games
can wesley make it a perfect 3-0 today
well a wanderer certainly hopes
no is the answer so we got a four
big games to follow as our our leaders
will
try to separate themselves absolutely
and i'm really thinking about uh
that incredibly bad timing for a wonder
that he had an obligation that prevented
him
from playing in the u.s junior
championship
and warming up with players like jeffrey
zhang and getting used to this time
control because he's
coming flat he lost his first two games
just as you said jen
and now playing the guy who's everything
is breaking
out well wesley so too no wants to make
it three you know
and hikaru drawing his way out of the
competition hmm
too early for that we know
it is a big game uh sam savion uh
playing well just beat wow i mean come
on he just beat lanier dominguez how
with the black pieces i mean he looks at
this game and he says
if i can get by hikaru unscathed
why can't i do better than anybody would
have expected
well they're still wesley and there is
still wesley
of course that's right but this is a big
game
a lot big round and jeffrey sorry sorry
but and jeffrey
and sam they're all good they're all
down but i'm just saying
you know you get one and a half already
and you get white against hikaru
car who's drawn his first two games and
away you go
sam's e4 now karu comes out with his
berlin
which i think we're about to see and
sam says oh sending went for the ending
he could have played rookie one
which i think is such a force drawing
line
sam would have walked out of here two
out of three and looking good
instead he's gone for the main main main
line but i'm happy that he
i mean the brilliant's not my favorite
don't get me wrong but
it does sometimes result in rich end
games whereas you pointed out there will
be one
um even a more just
flattening flattening of the position
and yeah he's playing with the white
pieces i
i you know of course nakamura is a
higher rated player but that doesn't
mean you
you trade off all the pieces and get a
draw with light no
absolutely not absolutely not if you
start saying
my opposition is better than i am that's
the first
draw with going down by the way remember
how sam
started the u.s junior i mean putrid
horror he came out of that just
miserable
and then how did he finish brilliant
four in a row nobody wants to play sam
savion
because he just went on a rampage and
played like
a hyper genius fantastic chess
and if he's as warm now as he was at the
end of that event
nobody wants to play him right now i
mean you know how he just
steamrolled lanier dominguez he's an
amazing talent
one of the top two talents we have in
the junior group
uh the the two top that is
jeffrey and him and he could be
anybody on a good day so i would say
hikaru
he sam should have the attitude i don't
care that it's hikaru nakamura
let's play chess let's see what happens
i'm going to play the most principal
moves
show my stuff and make it happen well
after all
sevillan did beat nakamura's record for
the youngest grandmaster in america
right so he's beaten him in that way
that's for sure um
but you know nakamura is so well
prepared in these lines so
it's going to be a challenge for him
let's see what other openings we have on
tap
ray robson such a well-prepared player
playing against another opening wizard
um former champion sam shanklin and
they've got a sicilian so that makes me
happy
i wanted to say uh i wanted to say jen
uh that
ray and sam started late i mean
the other games were definitely two
minutes into the action
and i wanted to draw your attention to
the game because it seemed like
there was a problem internet connection
problem or something was going wrong
that the game started late but by the
time you got back
to the game the game had actually
started so i'm wondering
what caused the hiccup and the delay so
we have a four night sicilian
uh classical sicilian i like to say in
this game
uh wesley so uh a wonder by the way
oh look at this the fantasy variation of
the karu khan
you are asking me what variations
against the karo khan did i find the
most uncomfortable
and today i would answer you only one
and that's the advanced karakan
the one uh variation i love
to play against was the move f2 f3 this
position
i almost felt like i was i skipped
from equality to being slightly better
so i gotta get the trifecta in you gotta
get the whole trifecta
now i actually thought that that the
position was refuted
by this move order by by black
and the idea of course is you can't take
my pawn because
this is very injurious uh
to your position you have to play knight
f3 and then i would play bishop
e6 and for some reason i actually
liked black's position i thought that
if this bishop can't go there
it's going to go e2 or d3 and like
black's position later i came to the
conclusion that the very best move
g7 g6 and then after e5 it's sort of
like
wait a minute now you're almost playing
a french defense
as white advanced french with f2 f3
as an extra move there's not even an
extra move
so i really think that the move f2 f3 is
not that
dangerous immediately c5 now that's not
what
i did in such positions i usually played
f6
as black when i was black here this was
my
choice but c five
by uh a wonder and
e6 bishop e3 oh where
well and wesley's back on move and has
sunk into
a little bit of the thought for the
first time in the game by the way
yeah oh go ahead what
i was going to say i was given this
nugget reminded
who ended wesley seoul's 45-game
unbeaten streak in a u.s championship
let me guess a wonder liang
i wonder how you got that right
was a setup question
really i forgot i think i remember
gotten as well wow a wonder
did end that streak last year so well
leslie's like you know what
i'm at the i'm gonna have to seek some
revenge against you but
i want to see lee has gotten a good
position right now
exactly he um captures on
it's it's a funny position in some ways
if
black you know easily easily wins back
his pawn
he's simply going to be better end of
story end of story
so then it so then it all comes down to
can white do some crazy machinations
where somehow against all the odds he
manages to maintain
one of the pawns either on c5 or e5
and if he can well then it's a big
advantage white but
and okay he has played bishop b5 but i
was about to say
i have my doubts that white can keep
uh one of one of the pawns the c5 or e5
because obviously if i take on e5 or
take on c5 um
black is just fine right i mean
i'll just prep all the way down right
now for rwanda
well i mean you you'd almost think to
yourself boy
i really much rather have my pawn on f2
right here right now than i would on f3
right i mean that
that that goes with you you hate that
pawn on f3 don't you
really match jen you had a point to make
you had an earlier point to make sorry
interrupting oh i just wanted to i
wanted to go more into the fantasy
variation and see
what yaz thinks about this specific
incarnation of
it so how do you feel about the way that
a wanderer played it are you still
happy yeah
you know a wonder shocked me it was his
game
against sam shanklin in the final round
of the us championship that sam
won uh and a wonder played a move
that i thought was a transmission error
was this e7 e5
and sam immediately snapped back h2h3
went on
won a wonderful game did sam to win the
u.s championship
fabiano was clutching the silver medal
complaining that he'd scored two and a
half out of three
in the last three rounds only to see his
opponent
his rival sam shanklin go 3-0 to win
that championship
so i i mean i definitely have my own
fixed ideas or i strongly held beliefs
i think that f7f6 i never
really experimented c5 i did something
that dissuaded me from it and i think it
was this move e76 i didn't follow it up
with e6
and it's very rare according to version
in fact
ivan when played yeah bishop g7 is the
main move
right and i want to say that i think
that a wonder is doing fine the crazy
part is
like i'm sure for for wesley he has the
same feeling like
why is the guy got a good position again
against me
who is this little kid that keeps
giving me grief well not all fantasies
come true right
queen c5 knight c3 are all on the board
now
and i think we should maybe check out
check in on the
uh the shanklin robson game it is still
theory no doubt
but it's fun to kind of look at such an
exciting opening
and how it's developing for those of
those of us who
don't know the theory here we have um a
very topical line
um in
variation bishop g5 preventing black
from just
playing for g6 right so that's why they
play bishop g5 so quickly
right and uh the pin by the way i want
to say that the
u.s chess scene is just bursting with
so many strong players that these two
sam and rey at one time must have felt
oh yeah
they're going to be playing in olympic
teams for
years to come and now they're fighting
uh for that spot so when these two lock
horns
it's a very very important uh match up
because
you know getting on the us olympic team
these days
is hard work oh yeah very with with
dominguez and then of course there's
jeffrey young
sam sabian creeping up it is
certainly a fierce fierce fight for
all all of the remaining spots i mean
the question
right i think i think fabie is feeling
secure
i'm not so sure that hikaru is feeling
that security
that's the classical rating right
exactly exactly
so wesley and fabio are like the two
ones that are like you know
100 percent and everything else is a
question right
the next two olympiads yeah uh g2 g4
very very topical uh line at the
sicilian that we've got in front of us
you guys are gonna have to tell me what
the latest and greatest is
in theory and how the percentages shake
out
you play it as white are you satisfied
with the outcome
do you expect or want more than
rey has or what's the story guys
a lot of things that can happen so black
just castled and a question
that often comes up in this and other
sicilians is
do you play the move bishop takes knight
which of course is
often a theme that maurice goes back to
in every position but in this specific
position it's very relevant too because
if black takes back with the bishop and
you take on b6
black will definitely get compensation
for the pawn
in the form of the two bishops and this
this constant option to take on c3
if they wanted exactly because the d5
square is well covered up so they're
never it's going to be hard for them to
to stop that and um the question is
whether you want to grab that pawn for
white
or play something more coy and of course
black has the option to take with the g
pawn but it's very very dangerous
especially once you cancel
usually if you speak with the g pawn in
the richter rouser you're kind of
chilling with your king on e7 and
trying to put your bishop on g7 that
kind of thing i think it's wonderful
and a wonderful insight absolutely
whenever your
castle your king in a richter rouser
you're you're more likely than not to
want to recapture on
f6 with a bishop go as you were just
saying
for that pawn sacrifices black because
your two bishops
your safe king your control of some dark
squares
are going to give you meaningful
compensation and
the other is just going to be like it's
funnier for it's much more fun for
white when he's got his pawn already on
g5
and he's attacking so oh whoa
oh sorry no go ahead finish i just if
you're gonna
switch in a moment if you don't take the
knight if you just drop your bishop away
so you can play g5
does that make sense uh or
is is that not the way you guys played
this very heart attack
very hard attack to simply execute what
black has counter play coming
quickly with b4 you have to worry about
d5
breaking in as well black's got play
black
definitely has play in this formation i
used to play the rouser myself
with the black pieces and you you get
your counter play going
it's a timing issue and what these
players have worked out sam just played
the retreating move
queen to d2 queen to d2
oh sorry ray did my fault my apologies
yeah ray just played queenie
this is a very slick little move if you
try to
sneak in d5 too early there can be an
e5 move that comes back at you
so your queen suddenly finds itself
trapped after a bishop to f4
whoa what did i do
nice little nuance that rouser players
have to suffer
every time we want to somehow make d5
come in the position
so watch out for that little trick
speaking of
little tricks uh this
little trickster i wander liang who's
growing up
fast but still is the youngest player in
the competition
look what happened in this game as he
played
this move queen e3 check
he said if you play knight to e2 then i
will
gladly play bishop to b5
get rid of my problem child trade off
those beats put my knight on e7 put upon
an h5
what problem could i possibly have in
this position
hello this is gonna be just fine for me
i got no worries no problem
he would be in his comfort zone
absolutely wesley said
no comfort for you i'm not going that
way
you can have my f-pawn wow
yes sir your feelings as wesley has just
given up this pawn play g3 ask the queen
where it wants to go
it has options by the way gets there on
the king's side i'm not happy with the
a6 square
or go to b4
and leave the king side and at f7 square
alone i don't know wesley's decided this
looks like a
straight pawn sack i'm willing to do and
i'm going to tell you if wesley wins
this game with this kind of enterprising
play
yeah who picked wesley to win well i
i i hate to be taking candy from
kids but that would be me
i mean happy halloween
trick or treat i mean you got to win
something
right so i didn't i did win
i'd be really impressed to see queen e2
and g3
sack upon right away and say i'm playing
for comp i don't care
let's go after winning two games the
first one you have to say fortunate win
after beautiful defense fight by
lenderman the second one
he really tested alejandro and at the in
the time pressure
alejandro failed to defend he was doing
a great job holding on
but i got to say what wesley did with g4
he
kept the chances alive in a position we
didn't think there was anything
right and now this game sacrament i like
seeing people play chess like this
he's looking fresh and creative and
getting fortunate
that's how you win a championship yeah
you just get
lucky uh when you need it in that
interview i saw that that
with hikaru he said there were certain
must-win games he felt that he had to
win and he won every one of them
let me just give an indication of why
wesley
might have felt so confident about this
pawn sacrifice so
imagine a move like queen b4 which
attacks the pawn on b2 and provokes
wesley from castling now you go knight
e7 now in an
an ideal world you mentioned the moves
h5 marie's
followed by knight f5 and you would say
hey
i'm i'm good to go i'm really golden in
fact
until white puts rook d4 on the board
now let's just again
continuing the play for a moment you
start to
you start to understand you know you're
starting to get a little bit troubled
here
the knight is coming to g5 your knight
can't go to f5
right away as the pawn will go to g4
and you start to think okay if the
knight ever lands on g5
the other rook will follow on f1 uh
i could be in trouble so let let me play
h5
as a prelude to jumping with my knight
to f5 and no
after knight d4 now you say i don't want
to go to f5 for a different reason
now the knight could capture and if i
capture with this pawn the rook
could go after my exposed pawn on h5
all of this led a wonder to play the
move that you didn't like
you said maurice the queen's not
ideal on h6 but he chose it
yeah and then h4 came with the idea of
bringing the knight to g5
we've seen we've seen this idea we saw
this when
uh irena crush played h4 against tatev
in her ninth round game in the u.s
women's championship
right put a knight on g5 and said we're
not leaving g5 and that night actually
did work uh enticing bat
moves weakening moves on that side of
the board actually
it it died quickly in that game but it
had real effect on the position now we
see queen f2
and i gotta say i wonder probably
thought he was going to positionally
solve this one
that his dart squared his light square
bishop was going to disappear
and he'd be okay yeah you showed that
line
with bishop b5 yeah things are not
working out i'm not
i don't want to do i'm not a materialist
i want to give you your pawn back if you
just let me trade off some bad pieces
right now unless they said no i gave you
the pawn you wanted the pawn
you've got it you snacked on it
congratulations
i hope you get indigestion when it's
done because
here i go knight g5 f7 is weak
there's a lot of defensive moves you're
gonna have to play if you are black in
this position
i'm not saying it's over but i really
like what wesley did
dangerous leon just cast a little but
let's take a pop over to some other
games because they're
pleased he wants version actually
reports that he carries
in some trouble against savion
this um line of the berlin quite well
it's it's a very very i
not only is it rare seriously it's not a
joke i cannot remember
ever upon the berlin
going from e5 to e7 like how did he do
it
is it good we'll find out let's see what
happens so we left it around these parts
and this is how we got the pawn to e7
and um he caro said no big deal
i'm gonna round up that pawn on my terms
is that
true he could take
on c7 can yeah that i think that's what
uh
what var was saying and he like set me
up position here because
okay maybe three take on f3
now i can't
sorry jen sorry i missed you you're kind
of sidelining your pieces a little bit
in order to win that pawn back because
rookie three right
right i guess you could go back night
before
it true i was wondering if there was any
benefit of uh including rook g
wanchak uh in the position
because that will allow you to retreat
with a tempo
knight d4 rook up and i'm
starting to wonder if hikaru
is comfy here well he does it does seem
that there's a lot of scenarios where
just
tons of pawns will come off and there
will be a draw but it's certainly white
who's the one who's pressing the
variations
even more interesting game even though
this one is very relevant to this uh
guys jeffrey you want to go sorry yes oh
yeah
aria has just played the move knight
very special visual move knight f3 check
i'm assuming this is all the
well-known theory it looks like both
players
are familiar but this move knight f3
check
man that's a nice tool knight c2
stop that jeffrey took a while to play
knight c2 i was monitoring this
it took a while to finally play knight
c2 and
darius took a while to play knight f3
so it as you can see the times where
they are
because as you say if it's all theory
why is he got less than half his time on
the clock
he spent a long time after knight c2
i mean he was blitzing out his opening
moves and then did a big tank i don't
know how much time he spent
but now he finally played knight f3
which requires
enormous calculation you are sacking a
piece
bishop takes f3 drops a piece
to black if black captures back
immediately so black has to looks like
black has to throw in rook to e5
right after bishop takes f3 throw in
this this protecting move this into
mezzo
and now take back on f3 and
jeffrey looking at this line this comes
as a shocker to him
trying to figure out what his best move
should be yeah 92
had been played only once before this
game whereas
queen h3 had been played numerous times
and speaking of queen h3
after after that line i guess the queen
will retreat to h3 there's not a lot of
other squares except for
g4 which could run into g rook g5
so that means if you said it's only been
played once that means
darius said i don't know what knight c2
is about
theoretically what should i be doing
and he looked for a refutation like
that's
that's attitude right there he looks for
a reputation
he i know him from millionaire chassis
he won the third edition
and to win to walk the gauntlet of
millionaire chess you have to go through
so much that wasn't
a regular swiss you had to first qualify
for the final four
and then beat people in matches yeah and
he eventually beat gawain jones in the
finals
and he just tremendous heart this player
is the first time
i met him and now he i mean he was a
student
at slu right with alejandro is he still
a student
four years later or maybe maybe he
should still be a student i think
but i'm not sure about that confirm yeah
and uh first chance of the u.s
championship guys and just dropped
knight f3 on jeffrey jean
exactly now if you look at the position
before jeffrey played in the move knight
c2
and you would say okay from white's
point of view what's
wrong with this position you look at the
knight on a3 and say that's what's wrong
with the position
put that knight on e3 put that knight on
d4
you're a happy camper so knight c2 looks
so natural you are after all a pawn up
at the moment the pawn is on g7 it's
going to be lost
but then you get to play rook here look
at this you got a
a backward pawn the knight goes to e3
what's the problem
well this is it knight f3 if
if black doesn't put knight off 3 on the
board
if you played a move like queen g7 and
then after knight f3
knight e3 you start to see the defects
are beginning to show up in the position
f5 the bishop is going to be tempo
maybe even black's king is a little bit
more vulnerable than whites
so this is the problem but now i've got
to ask the question
can jeffrey capture the knight
whoa and takes what if he just takes
takes and bishop so give me mate
well i mean queen g7 queen g7
we'll give you mate all right you're
gonna give me me
that wasn't well actually you do have
bishop jesus
66. david yeah you've down a piece
no no you're not down to people no no i
want a piece we want a piece of paper
right right right right oh just
be sick so yeah
but okay just a second hold on oh man
then i can't do what i wanted oh
okay wait wait wait why why why was
bishop g6 so bad
uh no just because he would pick back up
the b
cereal i could probably play
queen takes g6 and oh just queen takes
g7 yeah
i'm a little bit better yeah because
this guy is hanging well
or i guess you could move the bishop on
some random square as well
yeah like weird no queen queen h7
never mind never mind sorry sorry uh and
lastly king h1
ooh rookie fought and you're asking
really
really really nice thing for so rookie
five mike queen does it
bishop six that queen is looking
trapped yeah it's uh
it's not pretty is it everybody's
everybody's taking pot shots
they're revolutionaries and rook g2
oh that's a pretty one that's a pretty
one bing binge
you got got me nicely uh jeffrey decided
you know what
no parts of that party thank you i don't
want to deal with that
so i am going to play bishop f3 gf i'm
going to play
knight e3 and after the move
rook e5 now i'll bring my queen back to
h3
eyeballing this guy eyeballing this guy
but i've got a feeling knight c2 is not
going to be
repeated anytime soon this doesn't look
like black's unhappy here on the
contrary it looks like you can take a
look
yeah exactly that's a very good way of
starting uh
business by the way we i just a tactic
floated in my head
sure this position when the queen was on
h5 after rookie five
uh you do have the the funny
knight g4 ooh excuse me
yes oh an ig4 here yes right
so that if rook h5 of course knight f6
and you pick up
everybody it retakes winning for white
unfortunately black uh in can just
calmly play queen takes g7 and say oh
wow okay congratulations on your tactic
you better start thinking about saving
your life right now
because rook g5 would be devastating and
every move
instead played yeah
ricky want played and now
i mean this feels like black is the one
dictating whether it be bishop f3 or
bishop
e6 either one i'm just
i'm not liking white's position
white's king is much much more
vulnerable than his counterpart
so something didn't go completely right
here for
jeffrey let's just check in wait wait
wait sorry before you make another move
bishop e6 in that position you just
played bishop e6
queen can go to queen has to go to g3
right you can't well you can do this
maurice you can take
anticipating bishop h3 and rook d6
uh bishop e6 queen g3
yeah um finish your thought i'm just
i'm just wondering about this queen and
it's
it's yeah it just feels engaged in
nature but it looks like he's alive
still
that's why that's why dariush is taking
so long to move
because he's just he's just gone into
deep thought he played this knight f3
check
can you imagine how much time you spend
on knight f3 and then
at the end of it the guy plays a few
moves and you're going okay
i could almost taste the the taste of
his blood you know
i played knight f3 spectacular move
attack hit his queen
and at the end of it he's still alive
but yeah
he's trying to say my pawns may be
weaker than his or some what
huh so her gift
jeffrey kudos for cool calm defense
and he's play queen g3 just like i
worked it all out son
i'm not worried i know i mean there are
certain players that are just
so slippery for me anatoly karpov was
just
the guy you know you you think you were
just grabbing as like an eel and he was
just
he's slippering slithering away here
queen g3
and you know again if white gets in his
tempe
rook d4 rook e1 somehow and
nothing nothing lands against this king
he'll be okay it'll be everything looks
good
yeah it looks really strong let's just
jump back to the game
the the olympiad team
uh you know yeah look at it right i mean
this is what we hope
in these kind of browsers just a second
i messed up
okay we we left it after the move queen
d2 now i see this move queen d2
and i see it as making room for the
night but
it does cost time i'm not that big a fan
and sam said okay i've got my pawns on
v4
a5 i'm i'm aggressing here uh
what's up wow
okay is this common are you guys
familiar with this
knight sortie yeah tonight can go to h5
in rousers i got beat
memorably for me a night bitter memory
knight takes g7 sack
showed up in my my kitchen
i'm not even going to say who who did it
who was the villain
i don't see what a villain is but i
don't even remember who the villain is
what i'm going to lie and say
but anyway
it hurt your feelings yes that was
that's quite a maneuver
knight to g3h5 wow happiness to me for
white because
we've gotten this fractured structure
with your king on he ate and i get it
you're coming at me but didn't i open
you up for some cuts first i think so
there you go there you go uh you know
you gotta give
to get squares you got to give them and
ray's given his opponent certain time no
question
and open files but ray is
winding up he's winding up he's ready to
play the move g4 g5 and once that move
lands
sam's going to sam's going to regret
that this
is talk about regret talking about
regret
uh a sacrifice by
wesley uh early
has remained a sacrifice and a wander
has defended
so well that the sacrifice is looking
like a gift
really supposed to be an attack and
we're doing your thing
f6 showed up and g5
bold play by the youngster just
throwing the pawns in front of his king
away like go ahead amazing
amazing really beautiful fresh
conception and
i mean look at this position just hung
the g5 pawn
wow you do what you want
i mean amazing that's amazing i'm gonna
say that setup
is absolutely amazing and now
he is all over his opponent and i saw
i saw the the bar go nuts it looked like
he missed a win
oh uh wesley yeah playing
just reminding everybody wesley you know
2-0 going into this game playing for a
perfect score
against his opponent to wonder liang
who's 0-2
hoping that he doesn't go down badly and
shockingly enough it may be a wonder
who's winning
what what did he where was the bar when
when did things go
it happened i decided to turn the engine
on
yeah at the moment that i saw the bar
flash
and it was after rook e6 okay just an
absolutely extraordinary move
that you would never play like
you just would not play this move the
move is rook e
f eight rook e
f a just sidestepping
the threat and just getting ready to
push the pawn
it has a logic though maurice but it
does allow a nut
upon queen takes d5 but that allows
knight e3
so that would be problematic and the
logic is
to just push him baby like yeah
wow that's a move that is
absolute and winning by the way the
engine's giving a pisa
like wow demolition over
like over over i get it oh my goodness
by contrast in the game it looks like
the problem is that if
queen d4 there's rook d4 and then if
you're asking
your f1 is going to go because
now we see the bar there is giving dead
equality
wesley dodge a bully wesley
i mean i don't know what
incantations he said or blessings he got
but somehow he managed to take games
that probably should have been
one out of he could have had one out of
three if his first two opponents drew
their games
could have had one he could have had one
and a half this game he was losing
with if if the youngster had found work
at f8 he would have been in a world of
hurt
somehow i was going to walk out here
with two and a half points it looks like
looks like that just because if he wins
his bond back
it could you're saying even more yeah
yeah yeah wow
once you you see that's the thing chess
is a momentum game
it's a confidence game too right wesley
may have seen the move rook f8 and he
may have been cursing himself
underneath oh my gosh the guy's going to
play rook f8 i'm losing and he doesn't
now his heartbeat goes way up he says
wait a minute
goes down and his smile goes up his
smile goes way up
i mean you know like a wonder might
also have the feelings like i miss
something by the way
guess what ray robson looks like he's
about to crush
as sam and this blunder version
alerted me that this move a3 was a lemon
because look at this
bang e5 opening the bishop e3
oh that's lovely i mean to get you with
queen h6
no that's how do we how did we stop this
guy that e5 looked like a beautiful idea
oh my gosh what a gorgeous movie i mean
that is
visual it's ray playing beautifully guys
none of us picked him but is he playing
beautiful chess
oh i guess what we had to do guys is
somehow we had to get our bishop away
from d7 so that we could respond to this
with maybe something like pawn takes an
f6 and queen to g7
so that at least we don't have to resign
right so
the problem is that if f takes e5 queen
h6
we would love to bring our queen over to
the defense but the bishop
takes it sorry f takes e5
queen gen sorry did you want to play
queen h6 or just queen g5 check first
i'm not sure i was wondering but
either one looks absolutely terrific
for white yeah the problem is f5 never
helps because you're actually opening up
the g
file right so you might block it exactly
but you've got a more
even more brutal customer coming to get
you exactly yeah we probably want to
take immediately right
why not yeah no the king is on on skates
is trying to get out of there kfc
that's not going to get attractive at
all you may run but you're not
hiding
e5 is just one of those moves that
you know it's like there's no recovery
it's like
it it just destroys the position at once
i mean sometimes you blunder a pawn uh i
hate that
and you get to defend sometimes you
blunder a piece but unexpectedly you get
some compensation
e5 followed by king f8
beautiful this is a beautiful position
i was in trouble because i mean e5 was a
was a possible idea regardless of what
you did i mean
how about how about moves that i've seen
have that have both offensive purposes
and defensive purposes
or moves like rook a5 so you know the
queen can't show up on the g5 square
and somehow you defend laterally
that's what i'm saying is e5 just a very
strong threat rookie five queen h6
i mean anyway right it all looks good i
mean i was looking at something like
trying to move your bishop to like e8
instead of your move work a5 earlier
yeah and if i
no or i understand yeah yeah
is there a knockout here though oh oh
really rook is kind of weirdly
weirdly i don't buy it no i don't buy it
no no i don't know take on h7 and g5
that's not
that's not going to hurt bishop b7 and
we have to ship h7
you can do as well yeah this is
this is ugly i mean he's an ugly [ __ ]
don't want to do it you're right one
i think after bishop d3 i think the
threat of e5
was number one missed and number two
underestimated yeah that looks great
maybe
all you can do is something like bishop
e8 with the idea that if e5
um you take it with the f on and now
with queen h6
we at least have f6 this could be a real
saving grace from like immediate
resignation right now queen f6 is going
g7
um and we're still oh i don't worry
queen f7
queen f7 better yeah so clean into the
defense can be so crucial now
or that ray would have still go on e5 in
this line but
yeah well this looks good right
right this still looks uh advantage
white all day
but yeah i agree with you jen uh the
bishop
either retreating the e8 or maybe the c6
to
anticipate this e5 was necessary because
what we got
instead of this is not good
and alejandro have drawn as have
sam sebian and hikaru nakamura so we've
got some results in
um that leaves he a bit frustrated with
three three draws in the day though he
did have two blacks
all right there's some solace there but
i mean the
rapid chest i don't know if the
advantage of the white piece is as
great as it is in classical chess to
begin with but
i think you said it well frustrated uh i
think hikaru is going to
leave today a little frustrated now guys
as jeffrey young
i want i wanted to say i think ray could
just put the killing
uh the killing blow uh i mean
genius me uh look at this just
threatening maiden one
with g5 that f pawn almost
forcing the bishop to make room but then
you drop the f pawn with check and i
mean it's just like
disaster disaster disaster come up with
a move like
queen g5 yes a genius move like that
when i see those mate and one threats
jen that's that's that's the secret
that's the indicator sauce
that's the ending that's fine i'm here
i'm here check me over here
but for a lot of people in the audience
that's actually really important people
starting out they learn forcing moves
captures checks and i notice that a lot
of
youngsters forget about checkmate
threats but speaking of checkmates let's
go
over to the wild game between darius
and jeffrey because there's only a
minute left on darius's clock and
guess what if jeffrey wins this game he
will also have
two and a half as well by the way yes
i'm gonna i'm gonna say that queen g5
move there's a king d8
response you have to worry about oh king
v8 and queen g8 bishop
e8 defend and then and then that's
defended and now it's back to your
king on b2 and a2 could become weak as
well so be
be careful crazy you don't have to
should be five it's not over queen g5
looks obvious
but sam has a devious track at any rate
right bishop b5 you're saying queen c2
and queen b two yes we'll have to do
something besides bishop
b5 what's interesting about that
sicilian if you want to go back to it
for one more second since
since um putting out this cool line is
that the bishop on d3 is such a
wonderful piece
because it defends everything right
that the c2 square which is which is
what all of your energy is on
so right so but this line i would be
very suspicious if i were
white so queen g8 now is meant by bishop
e8 so we can play those two moves
and black does have a threat black
plastic take on b2
and then sack a rook potentially on a2
and then check on the a file bring the
two rook and the queen i mean
you don't know what could happen or just
play queen c3
you have to be really mindful in that
and that position
uh we don't see it on the screen right
now but it yeah in that position
yeah yes here i mean i play queen c i
play sacrinate too and
yeah you don't want to take i i get no
no no
it's real there is unfortunately for
black this bishop b5 to deal with
jen was mentioning that the bishop on d3
is so good
yes but you're right i have missed uh
king d8
i just saw queen g5 queen g8 mate
and that was why i think ray
actually played the move b3 he said you
know what
i'm a pawn up i'm not going to let you
sack on
my a2 square so i'll just play
uh b3 as a starter
maybe maybe something to be said for
bishop h7 and just push the h-bond home
as well
in any case yeah ray look ray looks
great
let's go to that game between jeffrey
and
darsh because it's a donnie brook this
is crazy guys
how often do you see a pawns on g7 and
g2
the wrong color yes and um
put that in your filter i know right
right
my filter says no we've never seen it
before nice look at this one
f4 and now f4 is the next move and now
at thirty just
blowed up what are we seeing in the
first day of the u.s championship
and f5 wow and now you know
darius was just a minute on the clock as
jeffrey's trying to blitz him he's got
seven minutes this darius goes under a
minute but what's the deal here if we
take that
what is the deal he's trying to take on
d6 with tempo
i think well first of all he's trying to
do that but he's also
up the tempo in terms of the pace of the
action
to try to exploit the clock because
maybe the position of jeffrey
frankly if you don't play this move
f4 i mean rook takes and h4
if pawn never gets h3 it's over so
maybe he was forced to undertake some
radical measures he's played bishop five
i think he's trying to play knight d5
though and just
win material with knight upset he did
you play knight d5 okay at any moment
what how does it matter black and give
us the exchange but
what is queen takes g7 g7 what's the
trick
yeah what is the trick knight e7
no 97 can he just take on d6 all of a
sudden because we're attacking the rook
on c5 and knight f6 that's
that's a big that's a big trick oh
that's a big trick
that's that's serious okay so queen
eight six
queen eight six holding on right
to go wait i gotta worry about queenie
three check in some crazy line
you didn't play queening four you have
three guys
again sorry jen what about queen f3
um he hits decision mark f5
who plays queen three what a move what
is that
but i don't know it's a good move it's a
good move knight f6
maybe you could just play queen
somewhere to protect the
well you can't play queen g6 because
there's 97 right
well hold on h5 is hanging too so where
where did you say i wanted is that
enough though because
you get i mean if you go sorry jen
um wrong right idea apparently wrong
square
as borussia i mean f2 is a winning move
so i i don't know why queen f3 wasn't as
good but i think
maybe the idea is that after queen f2
what's the difference guys why is this a
better move
queen first feels better because there's
nothing hitting this queen he puts it on
a dark square and
why would you put it on f3 but also
you're hitting c5 in an
x-ray kind of way right which is maybe
why
we do have queen f2 on the board by the
way
yeah and luke takes d5 was played what a
nice yeah he bailed out here played rook
takes d5 decided to give up the exchange
takes d5 this is on the board 11 seconds
left yes
who apparently goes by daryl sometimes
as well funny
because daryl um because that reminds me
of the
the former slu student who went by
yarrow right
euroslav yeah who played in our u.s
championships
and upset fabiano in a key
game uh beautiful game by urasov
so five pawns to four you could take on
a6 right now if you just don't
see any mate he's done it rook to g6
and now i'm worried about the back rank
somewhere something could happen
with a rook a8 and a queen d4 action
yeah he's got to watch out for little
trickies here doesn't joke rook f6 and
rook f1 is coming to disturb your
equanimity as well so
it's not play on one goal but five
minutes to 17 seconds so
jeffrey is the one with that i hate to
figure out what to do here
that's the problem is rookie six
possible
oh good am i being silly rookie six
right now
we have how many fawns though we only
have it's not about the pawns is that i
have a pass pawn on the queen side that
you may not be able to fight
if you could take off if i could take
all the rooks yeah
g7 and i don't have yeah i think that's
a good idea
especially if jeffrey was the one who
had 17 seconds i'd be like
rookie two a brilliant move
exactly one minute so he's probably
thinking about that among other options
but yeah this looks like a really i
could have actually won a pawn with rook
g7 by the way but instead he's
decided he knows me for a sacrifice
let's just play queen d2
that pushes the queen out of there
you know what i like that move because
it really goes to show that this queen
on h6
is in a kind of a no-man's box
and very quickly
queen g7 on the board we have some more
moves by the way rook d7
both players are moving pretty much
a tempo yeah just because he has to he
has 10 right
queen d3 check don't go back because
then there's work the eight
so bishop f5 played but it's looking
really bad as the black pieces are
are just becoming more discombobulated
in order to
to stay alive and now look at this he
can't afford to trade queens
it doesn't work d8 went on the spot yeah
workday it's forcing a queen trade and
meaning it's forcing resignation i would
think because you can't you can't trade
queens
actually i like queen of six better
queen of six
six is really nasty that's
like like you better trade queens if i
put my grabber i don't even move myself
he's played queen g8 right yes
i mean queen queen f6 wins but so does
rook d8 right i think
both of them do win yes yeah wow and
this means that jeffrey's going to
soar to two and a half and joint has ray
won yet let's see is ray won the game
yet
let me just check in one game between
ray
but three connected past pawns
i think he's going to win that one i
think the answer is
shortly shortly
7h8 shortly uh jen
actually we have a similar material
distribution in this game as we do in
the darius game
it's an exchange up queen and two rooks
versus queen working bishop
right if you put them side by side yes
sir bring up bring up the other game
uh the uh here we go so we have four
well it's four no no the you have the
game
this one yeah this one yeah so we have
we have their game on the left
here we see queen two rooks right right
up in exchange
and over the other side we have queen
and two rooks and open exchange and it's
the light square bishop as well
and a bad king it's like it's not quite
mirror images especially those two
connected past pawns
i'll take the one on the right over the
one on the i mean the one on the left
over the one on the right
take the one on the left i'll take
either one
right now i'll take either one no the
one on the left is
it is doom i mean the one in the seven
is dude
for sure yeah that's right but but it's
curtains either way the same
thing's happening as white is winning in
the same fashion
secure position and desperation by sam
taking on h1
uh there's going to be a second queen i
think
i think we'll take the queen yeah queen
g5 played as it's a race to who gets to
two and a half first then
queens that's what we're waiting on okay
speaking of who's going to get to two
and a half can we just check in
as we see yeah
it's happening on the right and wesley
sorry jeffrey too is winning uh jeffrey
dude was the first one to win but we'll
we'll see ray
i think join him at two and a half in
any moment but the question is will
wesley
join or surpass them because he fights
on against wanderly young who's only got
10 seconds left on the board oh no
that's bad
or 19 sorry what a material distribution
this is really strange
rook at night versus work at night fine
two versus two fine except
both sides have two past pawns each
it's like what yep and they're not
separated
yeah they're separated that is unusual
now the difference is white's pieces are
just a tad more
active uh than the counterparts which
means that white is for choice how big
an advantage i don't know but the time
gen time is such a factor now
how do you could be deciding this rook
b7 is coming
no matter what he just walked into king
h6
c7 he just walked into
c7 uh oh looks like an uh oh to me as
well
um that's not clear that's not clear
you gotta keep your apon alive and black
does have counterplay
so you rather just play rook b7 keep the
pawn
so maurice is like i don't even want to
give you a
i don't want to take a piece for a pawn
that makes sense after rook v7 i mean
maybe that's true
that h-pawn is real the struggle is real
my that h-bond is gonna mess up my
knight and
you might pick off my a-pawn and then
it's not a win anymore so wesley
is going to have to look at that one why
is sam still playing
good question um he just traded queens
even
i mean you can't even mate if i told i
gave you another move
well this is going to be over any second
guys as ray actually has the extra
minute on the clock as well
and rook takes d4 never mind queen takes
e5 but rook takes d4 is also a
massive threat uh that looks no no it's
not a threat it's a move
on the board he could have played he
could have actually oh wow yeah he just
he didn't play rook takes people how
could you not play rook takes anymore
that's amazing but okay uh sam
has given it up and
by the way and ray did it meanwhile uh
oh
nice move uh var pointing out knight g4
check and wins on the spot
with the idea for c7
oh very g4
oh that would have been a sparkling
sparkling similarity look at this kid
trying to fight back but i know what he
has a reputation oh he's a knight g4
czech refugee yeah
this is so sick when you play a move
like knight d7
it's like you you kind of make that
tactical association in your mind now
that you've seen knight d7
you have to see knight g4 right
because you're you play knight d7 to
attack the knight
so if you're gonna attack the knight
will attack the knight with check
true it's amazing that you can feel all
the other calculations
yeah cool idea i like that knight before
it's very
unusual it is it's beautiful
by the way 97 what do you do anyway i
mean i understand
i understand you can also resign in that
position but it's always
but i'm always thinking maurice that
even when i play it even when i play a
really really really good game
did i play perfectly well i understand
you want to be exact
and you want to win win with nike seven
in your in your puzzle rush or your
tactics frenzy right
that wouldn't give you points you'd have
to find knight g4 the reason i think
that moves like knight g4 are a little
harder to find like if this was a
challenge at the end everybody would see
it
because we don't give quite the amount
of love to promoting a pun as we do to
checkmate so it's like
a little bit of a block i think in the
brain and that's why
tactics like these involving pawn
promotion is something i think everyone
should work on
tonight 97 is completely winning let's
see
it's one of those three you know when
you look at when you look at stock fish
and stock
says knight g4 uh is
10.8 and knight d7
is 6.5 and you're going you know he
should have played that 10.85
because that's 6.5 we're not feeling it
it's like come on the guy was winning
completely
he he dodged a bullet by the way in this
game in that he should have we could
have
lost if the youngster had played
consistently
but he did get his revenge on him for
stopping his streak
that unbeaten streak as we talked about
and
3-0 to start the day guys
if he's up he's at 3-0 my pick is at 50
percent
that's very that's a big difference
that's not bad though maurice i mean
think about the us women's the thing
about this event is surprisingly because
you usually think that
the the stronger the field the more
likely you are to have bunched up scores
but actually
we have a lot of top-heavy scores after
three rounds i mean we do
we didn't have any three o's i think in
any of the events if i remember
correctly
the first time it was 3-0 and he could
anyway
could have gotten 3-0 but she didn't he
got two and a half instead
exactly yeah anna sadansky held it but
yes you're right right there it was no
3-0 in wesley
and we even had some events where we
didn't even have a two and a half i
believe the senior
so the fact that we have won the rio and
two two and a half
in a field this strong is already
remarkable but this is gonna turn out to
be an incredible event
exactly well wesley so has stolen the
lead or grabbed the lead
but boy i gotta tell you ray robson grab
the brilliancy with this game against
sam shanklin i mean sam is wondering
what did i just get hit with holy smokes
no
no i'm gonna say it's not just that game
if you have to pick somebody in terms of
quality of play remember the game
rey beat a wander by sacrificing in the
opening for compensation
only right and then it just was
sparkling i mean he's playing the chest
that you go
who's that guy who let him in the room
right he's he's playing the best chess
of everyone right now
no question is yes wesley has the
results
but ray is playing i'm like
he's playing pretty well too and it's
not just because he's my pick
what did you say but jeffrey's playing
pretty well too and not only because
he's my pick he seems like he's got
really good technique today but i agree
with you maurice
ray is is is making all the headlines
with his beautiful moves but
let's right now say hello to our leader
grandmaster wesley cell hi jennifer hi
how are you fellow hey yes sir hey
wesley perfect start to the day
how are you feeling about the games
yeah thank you well uh yeah it couldn't
be better
considering the results uh the quality
of the games were not
very high actually uh the the last game
was very
topsy turvious can be expected from this
electric arrogant
in fact just looking at the games at my
game briefly in the last round
the computer says i was lost at a couple
of points
yeah in fact yeah night after was a very
bad move because
i played too quickly i should play queen
d to first
instead of knight f3
and then and then i i thought white just
had a
large advantage here because his dark
square is very weak
and his pawn on g6 is undesirable so
after queen e3 check i couldn't really
bear myself to play a slightly worse or
equal in game after knight e2
bishop b5 i love black just no chances
to lose
so i thought a wonder had zero out of
two today so i just sacrifice upon
and see what happens but it could have
turned out pretty badly
when you realize things had really gone
wrong wesley
yeah it's funny because i played queen
f2 and i actually mixed
things up i was just missing a lot
because
my idea after queen f2 castle is to play
knight h2
but then he had finished five
i just totally forgot about
qh5 hmm
so in fact i should have played knight
knight g5
f2 maybe so around these parts you're
beginning to have doubts
that things are going in your favor
well i'm simply down upon yeah yeah
and uh apparently queen g7 was winning
instead of g5
and that that makes sense queen g7 and
knight c6
makes sense and
fall apart but
yeah the way i wonder played i had some
tricks like
knights and takes and g4 and here i
thought the game was
uh at least i'm fighting and not totally
lost
and after knight e5 queen d4
yeah i could have equalized somewhere
but here your ef-8 here which
was also very strong
at this moment sorry we were saying yeah
this was where maurice was saying the
rook f8
and well apparently you're in trouble
yeah it's a very strong move yeah you
got the fbi
uh we were reminded wesley
that you had quite a
long streak of undef undefeated games in
us championship history
and did you remember that it was a
wonder that had stopped your streak
like game 45 or something
yeah okay
you did remember that well you guys both
have two of the best smiles in the
competition
although it's you smiling after this
game wesley
um how have you uh been preparing for
this last couple weeks
for this last couple weeks well i'm
playing a lot of blitz games online
trying to keep my time up trying to get
you through the mouth
uh yeah are you playing with an
increment online like to actually
model this exact time control or more
just like straight 305-0
yeah it's more uh it's more
more blitz like uh three minutes or one
minute
uh i do have some inspiring partners
also with strong people online with some
of my friends
and we do this we do the standard time
control with with a five second
increment
let's say ten plus five fifteen plus
five
but in general i think uh
playing a bullet or trio is a good way
to practice your speed
because uh i i also actually watch uh
hicar1 on twitch and that seems to be
all he does day in day out
so you can't wait too wrong with it all
right all the parents at home are like
no
wesley just told our kid to play bullet
all the time
yeah in fact i was i was spying earlier
today with some bullet games
all right thank you so much wesley great
and good luck the rest of the way
thank you so much thank you for you guys
as he got three strikes of lightning
here he's got
a perfect 3-0 score um
some definitely some trials in these
games he was even in trouble in the last
one but hey
when it counted um he brought home the
point all three times and
never seemed to be in any time pressure
at all that's definitely huge in this
rapid format
absolutely and we got jx in the building
jeffrey zhang with a great start
congratulations jeffrey on your start so
far
yeah hey guys thanks jeffrey how you
feeling about your play
up to this point this last game was
absolutely insane
but you managed to set uh set the
position solid make the position solid
and and
cruise to a good win
yeah i think actually this position has
probably been played um
quite a few times but i couldn't really
remember how it went
and i might have just blundered this
knight f3 i don't know if it's
that good for black or anything but it
certainly looked good um
when he played it but fortunately i
think um
after 93 it's actually not so easy for
him to uh
to start any attack because his pawn on
g2 is kind of a nice shield for my king
and i don't know it felt like white was
actually
easier to navigate here
yasuo was pointing out have any of us
ever seen a black pawn on g2
and a white pawn on g7 in any game have
you done any of those
have you experienced any game like that
no i've never seen it i've never seen it
either
no i didn't either when
because we were we couldn't make heads
or tails ourselves
about it when did you feel jeffrey that
things were
going in your favor right here you
played the move f2 f4
but maybe you absolutely had to make
that
risky move uh did you feel it was going
good at this point when did it go good
yeah well i thought already here um
based on the way
he was spending his time i i had a
feeling he wasn't very comfortable with
this position and i think concretely now
i thought i was weighing in exchange so
i thought already here it seemed pretty
good for me
okay so right about here you were
feeling good
okay yeah and i'm still very very safe i
think
on the dark squares i just control
everything
one of the things that impressed me
about your play today jeffrey was your
technique it's so easy for people to get
winning positions in rapid but to
convert them without
any kind of hiccups um is something else
do you feel like you're in good form
um at least for today i didn't mess
anything up so i guess
for the moment we can say that um
my technique was fine so far
and um wesley we just had on the air
said that one of his preparation for
this tournament even earlier today
was bullet jazz um what's your take on
that is bullet helpful
for getting better at rapid
um that's definitely not the traditional
way
uh i think well i also uh
i think the concept is is good that you
should
try to play some games to warm up get uh
get get your head uh started but bullet
might
i i wouldn't i wouldn't play boy let's
let's just play like that
all right well thank you so much great
start get your rest
and good luck tomorrow thank you jeffrey
and this is actually wesley's 3-0 score
i feel like
wesley fans want us to just keep putting
that up 1-1-1 for wesley
but jeffrey's um score so far doesn't
look too bad either is he's got
two and a half including um some
big wins with the white pieces as he won
against awander
and darius both with some very nicely
played whites
exactly
we have sam sevion with us
congratulations on your day how are you
feeling about your playing
what's your favorite game so far um i'm
feeling good
this was a good day good start um
yeah i'm happy i played the junior
because i got a lot of reps i haven't
played
many rapid games in my life and
kind of showed today yeah the second
game was good
he put some pressure on me but i
defended well and
he made a mistake with knight c5 when
he got low on time
um so you're talking about your win
against dominguez yeah yeah
he had this new a3 idea but i think i
defended well
indeed a good start i was thinking you
would do it
here before you play a star game
and then uh you get you get nabing is
and you get nakamura
and you get a point and a half out of
that group
that couple that's got to be a good way
to start a chess tournament
yeah i definitely knew today was an
important day i needed to start strong
the first game i had a chance at the end
but
it always comes down to the end in many
of these games
and what is your feeling you mentioned
that this this is about
this is about being informed and rapid
have you thought of a
score you might need to win this event
or are you just taking it one day at a
time
i'm taking it one day at a time for sure
i mean many many of these tournaments
the scores vary for the winner
yeah you said you were happy that you
had the break between the junior
obviously the pairings were announced
for this a couple weeks ago
um so have you been able to get a lot of
concrete prep in
um yeah yeah for sure i've been working
pretty much every day since the junior
and um well today
my first opponent surprised me so i
didn't get anything against him but
the other two games were pretty good
yeah that does seem like an ideal
schedule you get like the training
tournament and then you get like
a week off it really really works out
well
and hey you and jeffrey both in great
form today so
it looks like it's turning out to be um
an excellent training ground for you
guys
definitely it definitely was are you
paying attention to the other
events you watch the seniors play you
watch the women play
have you been really hungry like
definitely
you want to jump in on this one no i've
been watching every day pretty much
so many interesting games and results
yeah for the last couple days i've just
been ready to play i mean i
my last junior day was really good i had
a lot of momentum i was hoping i could
play the next day
but i had to wait for a couple weeks or
so absolutely absolutely well you've
kept up the momentum
keep it going and good luck the rest of
the way
thank you sam good luck good luck sam
modestly put
he won his last three games of the
junior right
so yeah that's momentum i think it was
the last four
the last four yeah exactly and here we
have
these results so far i mean look at the
strength of the opposition two out of
three but also playing against two of
the top rated players in the field
nakamura and dominguez
so very very great start i mean great
start for sam
got a three in the junior and starts two
out of three against that field and the
u.s championship just goes to show you
how strong the players are on both the
junior side and u.s cast
and of course in this elite field where
hey
shout out to al shawn morata abadi as he
has started the
tournament with three solid draws as the
lowest rated player in the competition i
believe so
yeah um big start for el shawn actually
matter of fact i got a couple of stats
that just got sent in to me
i want to read to you from ed gonzalez
and he said first of all that point you
just made about el shawn
elshon is the only player in u.s
championship history
without a loss ever
he's only played three games but hey he
for the moment
he's the only player in the history of
the u.s championship who's undefeated
pretty funny one and also here goes one
for you
in round robins who is the last person
to start
three and oh in a round robin
the last person to start 3-0 and around
robin
this is a really good one a u.s
championship round us chair bishop round
robin not a swiss not the swisses we've
had
a u.s championship ron robin this is a
really good one
i'm not jennifer you i think jen you i
think was two and a half out of three
well i mean i mean this championship oh
you mean the the
open championships yes not
not any of the the the the swisses
got it kamsey i mean jesus it's really
good did it
got it was 3-0 in 2013. but that was a
swiss
okay sorry this is this one is a really
easy one
yasser zero one really
i started three you know yeah yesterday
started 3-0
in 1994
1994 the last player
to start 3-0 in an invitational
now this is not a classical tournament
so
there might be a small asterisk next to
the record but
we're going back to 94 for a 3-0 start
by
is that that crazy that means the bishop
prize
was ending fast in a lot of events
oh it was all our events to go three and
oh is pretty special to start
if there was a bobby fischer prize in
1994 i would have remembered
and i would have been playing really
hard that fourth game i'm sure whoever
was playing against me
would have been playing really hard too
by the way which provokes the question
jen
is there a bobby fisher prize for the
2020 us champion
[ __ ] um i believe the answer is yes i
have to double check
um not maybe not a million bucks
i don't know a million
i think i saw something about it but um
i'll double check of course it's
extremely difficult
to get that as you know you have to win
um all 11 games in honor of bobby
fischer's
prize um actually maybe not maybe there
isn't i don't think there is this year
you know i think it was in when the u.s
championship was announced
when it was going to be in person they
announced it but then when then
the format changed a little bit online
gotcha
it's obviously at any rate it would be
wesley could do it now right
right only wesley
so the way his lucky stars are going he
might go
run up the score because he got through
today when he
yeah that does make sense but hey wesley
is the only person
in all five tournaments to start with
real so seriously that's just that he's
you know matching your record yeah
i didn't know i had a record sorry
no but that is uh that's fantastic 3-0
uh
very fortunate very fortunate to have
that biggest score
considering the positions he had yep
and we will see you guys tomorrow for
more for
the us chess championship where we'll
see if wesley can continue
perfection thank you everyone for
joining us and sharing your day
have a good night good night
you